Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast, über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Frittlov.
Und nach einer korona bedingten Pause geht's wieder weiter bei uns im Programm und wie sollte es anders sein? Es gibt genug
worüber man reden kann und jetzt bin ich auch dabei, all die Themen wieder aufzugreifen, die ich ohnehin schon auf meiner Liste hatte. Äh ja und
heute geht's mal richtig um Technik und zwar im Rahmen einer, eines Themenbereiches, den ich hier schon mal,
abgedeckt hatte, nämlich vor vier Jahren, gings um Gravitationswellen, beziehungsweise Gravitationswellen, Astronomie einfällt, was im Prinzip so vor vier Jahren,
eigentlich erst so richtig geboren wurde und dann sein großes Coming Out hatte, weil es das erste Mal unter Beweis stellen konnte, dass ich all die Anstrengungen über lange Zeit,
gelohnt haben. Heute wiederum möchte ich das Thema von der Seite aufgreifen, mal ein bisschen ein tiefer einzusteigen, was eigentlich hier für eine Technik wirklich zum Einsatz kommt, um diese ganzen Gravitationswellen zu detektieren, diese,
ganze Astronomie auch aktiv zu betreiben und wohin die Reise geht,
und dazu habe ich mich selbst mal auf Reisen begeben und bin jetzt in Sarstedt hier auf dem Acker, kann man fast sagen, an einem Ort, der heißt Geo sechshundert, ein Forschungsstandort für Gravitationswellen, Gastronomietechnik.
Und das Ganze gehört zum Albert Einstein Institut, das ist äh in Hannover,
und jetzt begrüße ich aber erstmal mein Gesprächspartner für heute, nämlich den Harald Harald Lück. Hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Du bist äh an diesem Albert Einschalten Institut ähm beschäftigt, vermutlich schon eine ganze Weile. Ich.
Ja, ich ich bin hier schon eine ganze Weile beschäftigt. Äh ich staune selbst immer, wie lange es jetzt schon ist, äh ich habe dreiundneunzig angefangen in diesem Institut,
damals äh war es noch sehr klein und unsere erste Aufgabe hier äh war dann tatsächlich ein Gravitationswellendetektor zum Bauen.
Also sozusagen von Anfang an äh im Thema.
Von Anfang an im Thema, ja.
Mhm. Also das ist das Albert Einstein Institut, das ist so eine Melange aus einer Max-Planck äh also im Institut der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft, für Gravitations äh Physik, aber die Universität Hannover steckt da auch noch mit drin.
Es ist ein Gemeinschaftsinstitut äh der Leibniz Universität Hannover und der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft,
streng genommen, ist das Albat Einstein Institut der Max-Planck-Teil und besteht aus zwei Teilen, wir haben einen Teil in Hannover,
der sich mit Datenanalyse und Experimentellenaspekten beschäftigt und ein in Potsdam, also in Golm, genau genommen vor den Toren Potsdam, da geht's mehr in die theoretische Richtung bis hin zur Mathematik.
Mh
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir zum Beginn doch nochmal ein wenig zusammenfassen, äh in welchem Bereich wir hier uns äh bewegen und nicht ohne Grund, weil die letzte Sendung auch relativ ausführlich. Ich glaube, das waren dann auch,
zweieinhalb Stunden, die wir äh darüber gesprochen haben. Das will ich jetzt nicht alles wiederholen, aber dass man erstmal so einen gewissen,
Einstieg hat, ähm, wäre doch, glaube ich, nochmal ein grober Überblick ganz hilfreich,
Wir schauen ja jetzt hier auf etwas, was eigentlich.
Als Gedanke, als Idee, gerade mal hundert Jahre lang existiert. Neunzehnhundert äh
sechzehn wurde von Einstein im Rahmen seiner gesamten Forschung zu Gravitation und dem Universum äh unter anderem positioniert, dass es so etwas wie,
Gravitationswellen geben könnte, die letzten Endes, ja,
Schwingungen sind die Auftreten bei extrem großen Verkehrsunfällen auf kosmischer äh Ebene. Also, wenn extreme Massen zusammenkommen,
zusammenprallen, miteinander interagieren, entstehen solche äh Rüttler im Raum Zeitkontinum. Und das war, ja, im Prinzip eine rein mathematische Vorhersage kann man sagen, oder? Also, das.
Das war eine rein mathematische Vorhersage. Ä,
und es war auch so, dass ein Stein selbst da noch ein paar Mal hin und her gerissen war, ob denn das jetzt nicht doch arte Fakte seiner Rechnung waren, ob da irgendein Realitätsbezug dabei ist. Stellte sich dann auch aus,
dass äh einige der Gravitationsfällen Sorten, die ja gewissermaßen vorhergesagt hat, auch tatsächlich Artefakte der Rechnung waren.
Aber.
Äh die die Theorie dahinter wurde dann von äh mehr und mehr Leuten untersucht und äh man kam zu der Überzeugung, dass das schon alles seine Richtigkeit hat, dass das Experimentell nachweisbar sein muss.
Und die Experimentellen nachweise oder die Versuche von von experimentellen Nachweisen, haben schon vor relativ langer Zeit begonnen, man hat dann äh sich Gedanken darüber gemacht, was für Effekte hat denn so eine Gravitationswelle und wie kann man,
die messen, wie kann man die experimentell nachweisen? Es gab dann,
ähm schon in den äh in den fünf späten Fünfzigern, frühen Sechzigern, gab's schon die Vorschläge, Verfahren zu verwenden, ähnlich den, wie wir das heute machen.
Ähm aber die Gravitationswellen,
die experimentelle Gravitationswellen, Forschung fing dann eigentlich mit einem anderen Prinzip an. Nämlich äh mit Joe Webber, der ähm sich große.
Massen genommen, hat also Aluminiumzylinder waren das in dem Fall. Und äh ein solcher Aluminiumzylinder ähm muss, wenn eine Gravitationsfälle.
Diesen Zylinder passiert, wenn also die Raumzeit gedehnt und gestaucht wird, zu Schwingungen angeregt werden. Und das hat Weber versucht, nachzuweisen,
er hat zu dem Zweck dann mehrere solche Apparate gebaut.
Und ähm die Messung bei der ähm beider dieser Aluminiumzylinder hat da miteinander korreliert,
hat dann festgestellt, äh dass es da Korrelationen gab und hat das als ähm eine experimentellen Nachweis von Gravitationsfällen auch in den Sechzigern,
veröffentlicht.
War denn zu dem Zeitpunkt, also am Anfang hat anscheinend als vorhergesagt und ich und er hat ja im Prinzip gesagt, so, ja, also das kommt jetzt hier bei meinen Gleichungen raus,
aber ob man das jemals äh wird messen können oder ob ich überhaupt äh richtig liege, ist total unklar. Ab ab welchem Punkt war man sich denn eigentlich sicher.
Das ist das, was das ist das geben müsste oder war das eigentlich bis zum Schluss? Unklar
weil man ja noch nichts hat messen können. Also war, war jetzt dieses erste Experiment von Joveva schon so ein okay, wir sind uns jetzt alle einig, das müsste da sein, dann können wir auch mal anfangen, was zu bauen,
und da waren das einfach nur so ein paar äh Einzelkämpfer, die von ihren Kollegen äh milde belächelt wurden, so nach dem Motto ja Gravitationswinden meinetwegen, aber kommt nicht so spät nach Hause.
Diesen Aspekt hat es lange Zeit gehabt. Äh das stimmt schon. Ähm man muss sich auch vor Augen halten als Einstein vor hundert Jahren die Gravitationswellen postuliert hat,
da war von den jetzigen Systemen, von denen wir Gravitationswellen messen, überhaupt nichts bekannt. Ähm, dass es neutronen Sterne gibt, dass es schwarze Löcher gibt,
da dachte niemand dran. Also es dachte niemand da dran, dass es so schwere und so kompakte Objekte gibt, die sich dann auch mit hinreichend hohen Frequenzen hinreichen, hohen Geschwindigkeiten bewegen können.
Also dich nur die Technik nicht, sondern eben auch rein kosmologisch.
Rein kosmologisch war da nichts in Sicht. Genau.
Okay. Mhm.
Und man kann sich aus den Formeln, die Einstein aufgestellt hat, relativ leicht ausrechnen, dass man mit irdischen Mitteln, also wenn, wenn ich zwei
Stahlkugel nehme, wenn ich einen Stahlträger nehme und den an der Zerreißgrenze rotiere, irgendwelche solchen äh solchen Szenarien,
kann man sich leicht ausrechnen, dass da bei Gravitationsfällen imitiert werden, die viel zu schwach sind, um sie nachzumessen.
Auch so Planetare, Konstellationen sind da noch nicht ausreichend, oder?
Planetarekonstellationen sind äh von der äh von den Frequenzen her einem völlig falschen Bereich. Das können wir auf der Erde nicht messen. Also da muss man dann andere Messmethoden verwenden,
könnten wir auch noch drüber reden, was es noch für andere Messmethoden gibt,
aber mit den Methoden, die wir heute auf der Erde verwenden oder auch mit den Methoden, mit denen es anfing, die so verwendet hat, wäre das im völlig falschen Frequenzbereich.
Mhm. Also war eher so im Prinzip so der, der Pionier, der sich das erste Mal getraut hat, auch wirklich mal was zu bauen, aber zu richtigen Ergebnissen dürfte das da noch nicht geführt haben.
Er war der erste, er man kann auf jeden Fall sagen, dass er der Pionier äh sagen, einer der Pioniere, der Gabitationswellenforschung war,
und die Tatsache, dass er dann Ergebnisse veröffentlicht hat, von denen er behauptete, dass sie durch Gravitationswellen verursacht wären. Das hat eigentlich die ganze Forschung dann in Gang gebracht. Also wir können heute sagen, das kann nicht gestimmt haben,
seine Apparaturen waren überhaupt nicht empfindlich genug dafür.
Aber zumindest wurde irgendwas gemessen und alle dachten so, hm, vielleicht ist doch was dran.
Es wurde etwas gemessen äh und alle haben gedacht, äh das ist ja interessant, das gucken wir uns auch mal an.
Und dann haben sich einige Gruppen das angeguckt, unter anderem auch in Garching, bei München eine Gruppe.
Die haben dann relativ schnell festgestellt, das kann überhaupt nicht sein. Ähm diese Sorte von äh Detektor von Resonanzantenne, wie es auch gerne genannt wird, ist nicht empfindlich genug. Da muss irgendwas im Aragen sein.
Ist insofern ein bisschen tragisch als Jo Webber, Zeit seines Lebens, äh darauf bestanden hat, doch doch, das war richtig. Mein Detektor hat das gesehen.
Also er war definitiv ein Pionier, der Gravitationswellenforschung und ist dadurch dann so ein bisschen ins tragische Verkehr, dass er,
äh an an der Detektion, von der der Rest der Welt überzeugt war. Nein, das kann so nicht gewesen sein, festhielt, bis zu seinem Tod, ich glaube, im Jahr zweitausend.
Mhm. Hm. Aber er hat immerhin was losgetreten.
Er hat was losgetreten auf jeden Fall. Die Kollegen haben sich dann also auch erstmal auf solche Resonanzanten gestürzt,
und sich das alles angeguckt, äh haben dann relativ schnell festgestellt, dass ähm ist es nicht,
da sehen wir nicht das Potenzial um die für die Zukunft hinreichend empfindlich zu machen.
Aber zu der Zeit kamen dann auch die Idee auf das auf einer anderen Art und Weise zu machen.
An der Stelle nochmal klar machen,
um was für was für Schwingungen es sich hier handelt oder oder was eigentlich letzten Endes gemessen wollen werden soll, weil wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, da kommen dann zwei schwarze Löcher und knallen aufeinander und dann macht's und dann zittert irgendwie äh äh die Raumzeit
könnte man sich natürlich jetzt alles Mögliche vorstellen, aber die Schwingungen, die wir ja letzten Endes hier auf der Erde empfangen haben,
sind ja dann letztlich Bewegung, die sich so,
subatomaren Bereich bewegen, also die Atome schaukeln ein wenig von links nach rechts und das ist eigentlich das, was wir messen woll.
Das ist das, was wir messen wollen, ja. Ähm es sind unvorstellbar kleine Änderungen, die wir da versuchen zu messen,
Also die, bei der ersten Gravitationsfälle, die wir dann zweitausendfünfzehn gemessen haben, war die relative Längenänderung zehn hoch minus einundzwanzig.
Ein äh, ein, ein Zollstock, sagen wir mal, von zwei Meter Länge,
der hätte sich also um zwei, mal zehn noch minus einundzwanzig Meter geändert in der Länge. Das eine unvorstellbare kleine äh Distanz, eine unvorstellbar kleine Bewegung.
Aber die wollte man messen.
Die wollte mal messen und die haben, wer jetzt auch gemess.
Aber nicht, aber nicht mit Resonanzanten sozusagen.
Nicht mit, obwohl sich äh das Konzept der Resonanzanten dann auch noch eine ganze Weile gehalten hat und äh auch noch deutlich verfeinert wurde,
Die thermische Bewegung der Moleküle, also die thermische Anregung durch die Raumtemperatur ähm war deutlich zu groß, sodass man äh dann die Temperatur erniedrigt hat. Man hat,
solche Resonanzanten dann bei kryogenen Temperaturen, um subcalving Bereich.
Gebaut und getestet, hat damit auch beeindruckende Empfindlichkeiten erreicht.
Kevin. Ich dachte, Kevin kann ich negativ werden.
Nein, aber ich kann ja äh also wenig weniger als ein Kelvin, also im im, also nicht, natü.
Also niedrige okay, also es ist ja okay. Unter ein Kelvin.
Also nicht natürlich nicht im negativen. Das geht tatsächlich nicht.
OK, also sehr kalt.
Sehr kalt, sehr weit runtergekühlt, sodass die thermische Bewegung ähm minimiert wurde,
hat damit auch beeindruckende Empfindlichkeiten erreicht. Ähm aber zu dem Zeitpunkt war es auch schon klar, dass eine andere Messmethode, nämlich mit Interpharometern, mit Licht das zu messen,
ein größeres Potential hat.
Deswegen wurden äh die dann aufgegeben. Die Resonanz sind wurden dann aufgegeben und das würde sich auf äh auf Interverometer fokussiert. Und das hatte die Garchinger Gruppe auch schon relativ äh früh erkannt,
und dann einige Prototypen gebaut. In steigender Größe, was dann in einem dreißig Meter, in dem Garchinger dreißig Meter Prototypen äh endete, an dem viele Techniken dann getestet wurden.
In in welchem Jahr sind wir jetzt angekommen gerade.
Äh
dass die Idee der, das mit Interverometern zu machen, ähm also vom vom reinen Konzept her gab's da schon äh in den Fünfzigern,
in den sechzigern wurden dann erste Vermieter aufgebaut, also einer der Nobelpreisträger jetzt im Zuge der Gravitationsdetektion.
Ähm hat sehr detailliert aufgeschrieben, welche Rauschquellen, die Empfindlichkeit limitieren,
wo, an welchen Ecken man äh Verbesserungen anbringen muss, also es war schon sehr umfassende Liste.
Des Arbeitsprogramms, was man in Zukunft erledigen muss.
Aber das Ganze war ja im Prinzip getriggert auch durch die Erfindung des des Lasers. Also das war ja dann die Voraussetzung oder reden wir jetzt auch von Interpherometern, die ohne Leser arbeiten.
Naja, man kann natürlich auch Interviewmeter bauen, die ohne Leser arbeiten. Also, ich meine, das, Michael sind Interviewmeter, hatte selbstverständlich keinen Laser. Ähm, das geht auch, aber äh mit den Lasern äh ist kann man das Ganze natürlich um viele Größenordnung in der Empfindlichkeit steigern.
So dass das also auch von vornherein so angedacht wurde, dass man das mit äh.
Ja, ja.
Das wurde von vornherein so angedacht. Und im Laufe der Jahre wurden die Techniken dann immer weiter verfeinert ähm und äh die Gruppe am Max-Planck-Institut äh in Garching. Ä,
mit dem dreißig Meter Prototypen hat da auch entscheidende Techniken entwickelt, die auch heutzutage noch äh benutzt werden.
Was wurde denn dann genau gebaut? Also was, was, was war denn dann jetzt die Idee.
Die Idee war äh mit einem Interverometer, also mit Licht, äh die Längenänderung zu messen. Also man erzeugt sich erstmal nicht, das macht man äh mit einem Laser.
Diesen Laserstrahl schickt man dann über zwei möglichst große Entfernungen.
Das sind bei GO sechshundert, wie der Name sagt, sechshundert Meter, beim Garchinger dreißig Meter Prototypen waren's damals eben noch dreißig Meter.
Und bei den äh großen Gravitationswellen, Detektoren sind es bei bei Wirkung, in der Nähe von Pisa, sind es drei Kilometer und bei den Leigo-Detektoren in den USA sind es vier Kilometer.
Und in der Zukunft wird das vielleicht noch größer werden.
Man schickt also diesen äh man man äh spaltet mit einem Strahlteiler, diesen Laserstrahl in zwei Teilstrahlen auf, ähm schickt die im rechten Winkel los,
weil die Gravitationswelle in der einen Richtung, wenn sie in der Einrichtung eine Längen, eine, eine Dehnung macht, äh macht sie in einer anderen Richtung Senkrecht, dazu eine Staupunkt, das heißt, man erreicht den größten Effekt, wenn man,
neunzig Grad zueinander misst.
Schickt also diese beiden Laserstrahlen über eine möglichst große Entfernung, reflektiert sie hinten mit dem Spiegel, beziehungsweise zum Beispiel in jedem Ende ein.
Ähm schickt sie wieder zurück und überlagert sie an dem Strahltaler wieder.
Und wenn sich nichts geändert hat, müsste er im Prinzip wieder dasselbe rauskommen.
Wenn sich nichts geändert hat, dann ähm geht jetzt einer der Teilstrahlen äh zu der einen Seite vom äh Strahlteiler raus, also wieder zum Laser zurück und der andere Strahl,
überlagert sich dann zum anderen Ausgang. Und die Intensitäten, die man an diesen beiden Ausgängen sieht, wenn man keine Verluste hatte, ähm, addiert sich das natürlich zu dem, was man reingeschickt hat,
und ansonsten hängt das Verhältnis davon ab, wie die relativen Längenänderungen sind, also wie die äh Phase des Lichtes, da bei der ähm bei der Überlagerung ist.
Die Helligkeit, die man jetzt an diesen beiden Ausgängen sieht, die hängt davon ab, wie die beiden Strahlen miteinander interfrieren. Also, von der,
von der relativen Phasenlage der beiden Felder, die da ankommen.
Also wenn sie die Phasen identisch sind, dann addieren sie sich, dann ist es heller und wenn sie halt in irgendeiner Form gegeneinander verschoben sind, dann ja quasi zeitlich,
verschoben sind oder sagen wir mal, Raumzeitlich verschoben sind, äh dann nimmt die Intensität entsprechend ab und daran kann man halt sehen,
hm, da muss sich ja was in unserer Raumzeit verschoben haben.
Ja, man muss jetzt erstmal ähm sich überlegen, an welchem Zustand war in welchem Arbeitspunkt bin ich denn am empfindlichsten.
Wenn ich jetzt sagen wir mal an dem Ausgang, der nicht zum Laser zurück äh geht, die Intensität messe,
dann würde man eigentlich sagen, okay, wenn ich jetzt die Länge der beiden Arme relativ zueinander ändere, dann ändert sich die Intensität am Ausgang, das das geschieht sinusförmig.
Und äh intuitiver wird man jetzt sagen, da wo der Sinus die steilste Steigung hat, also bei halber Helligkeit, da bin ich auch am empfindlichsten.
Aber das aus technischen Gründen wisst man da nicht. Mit Regel schleifen, stellen wir die relative Armlänge so ein, dass sich an unserem Messausgang,
die Lichtfelder nahezu aufheben. Also, dass wir äh sehr nah bei destruktiver Interfrent sind. Das hat hauptsächlich technische Gründe.
Wenn wir an unserem Messausgang eine niedrige Intensität haben.
Und wir in den Interverometerarmen wenig Lichtleistung verlieren, geht zwangsläufig das meiste zum Laser wieder zurück.
Da können wir einen Trick anwenden und dieses Licht, was zum Laser zurückgeht, können wir dann äh nochmal in das Interverometer nochmal zum Strahlteiler Richtung Strahlteiler schicken und recyceln.
Das Ganze nennen wir dann Power Recycling, weil wir die Laserleistung recyceln und können auf diese Weise die äh Leistung, die Lichtleistung im Interverometer stark überhö.
Dass auch eine der Techniken, die damals in Garching ähm erfunden wurde, am dreißig Meter Prototypen ausprobiert und heutzutage in allen Teferometern angewandt wir.
Dieses Prinzip hat sich ja dann eigentlich gehalten. Also man hat dann relativ,
schnell ist man zu der Überzeugung gekommen, dass das der richtige Weg ist. Aber jetzt ist ja bis zweitausend äh sechzehn.
Sozusagen noch nichts gefunden worden. Also es gab ja in dem Sinne keine Bestätigung dafür. Warum war man sich so sicher,
dass dass dieser Technologische Ansatz jetzt der Weg ist, den man verfolgen will, gab's in dem Sinne keine Alternative oder war es irgendwie absehbar
dass, dass das genug Potenzial hat, äh die entsprechende Sensitivität zu erreich.
Also erstmal von der Seite der Existenz der Gravitationswellen ähm war man durch die Analyse der Theorie überzeugt, dass es die geben muss,
und das hat natürlich nochmal einen großen Push gegeben ähm durch die Beobachtung, die Hals und Taylor mit äh ihrem Pulsar gemacht haben, wo man also zeigen konnte,
durch eine Analyse der Umlauffrequenz in einem Doppelsternsystem, dass dieses System Energie verliert.
Und dieser Energieverlust mit der erwarteten Abstrahlung der Gravitationsfällen exakt übereinstimmt,
hat also ein System beobachtet, aus zwei kompakten Sternen, die einander umkreisten, einer von den beiden ist ein Pulsar, der gibt also immer elektromannetische Blitze,
ab mit extrem konstanter Periode.
So dass man äh diese Licht oder diese elektromagnetischen Blitze, die Radioblitze kann man als, als eine Uhr benutzen.
So dass man die Umlaufperiode dieser beiden kompakten Sterne umeinander extrem genau bestimmen kann. Und man hat festgestellt,
dass das Gesamtsystem Energie verliert, sich immer näher kommt und dadurch die Umlaufperiode kürzer wird.
Das hat man, äh, das, das haben Hals und Taylor äh über einige Jahre beobachtet. Äh, sie haben, sie konnten dadurch auch auf die äh Parameter des Systems zurückschließen und aus dem Paraden, also wie zum Beispiel die Massen und äh die Entfernungen.
Und konnten daraus ausrechnen, wie viel Energie dieses System in Gravitationswellen abstrahlen müsste.
Und stellte sich heraus, dass der Energieverlust des Systems durch äh Gravitationswellen exakt mit der Beobachtung übereinstimmte.
Das hat man ähm also das äh haben die beiden veröffentlicht. Es äh gab auch einen Nobelpreis für den indirekten Nachweis von Gravitationswellen.
Neunzehnhundertdreiundneunzig gab's den Nobelpreis, genau. Mhm. Ah okay. Das war dann.
Das hat man, das hat man ähm,
bei mittlerweile noch bei vielen anderen Systemen äh beobachtet ähm und kann auf äh die Weise auch die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie schon relativ genau überprüfen anhand dieser Systeme.
Ich habe jetzt mal gerade nachgeschlagen, also die Beobachtung war von vierundsiebzig, also vierundsiebzig haben sie das entde.
Chtzig, wenn ich das richtig sehe, äh dann diese ganzen Berechnungen äh veröffentlicht. Das heißt, das war so denn so der Moment, wo dann auch noch dem Letzten klar wurde, so okay, alles klar, das das Gips. So, das das.
Den Letzten wird es nicht geben.
Ja gut, aber sagen wir das mal andersrum. Das war ein,
ein ein weiteres Indiz, was einfach Leute, die ohnehin schon in diese Richtung marschiert haben, einfach genug Futter gegeben hat, zu sagen, so, okay, jetzt
die man mal richtig Gas, weil ich meine, äh hat ja auch immer ein bisschen was damit zu tun, wie viel Geld man für so eine Forschung äh letzten Endes auch einsammeln kann und ich kann mir vorstellen, das dürfte am Anfang relativ schwierig gewesen sein für so eine äh doch relativ esoterisch daherkommende
Forschungsgeschichte.
Ja, also das das äh ist natürlich schwierig ähm und äh man fühlt sich auch wie ein bisschen wie in so einer Esoterikerecke,
ähm inwieweit jetzt die Entdeckung von Hals und Taylor, mit der Finanzierung der größeren Detektoren zu tun hat, kann ich nicht sagen, was.
Ja gut, aber äh es hat dazu beigetragen, dass innerhalb innerhalb der Wissenschaftscommunit.
Selbstverständlich. Ja, ja.
Selbstvertrauen angesammel.
Genau, genau. Also und man kennt mittlerweile relativ viele solcher Systeme, ähm also auch in völlig unterschiedlichen Größen,
ähm man kennt ähm auch ein äh sehr, sehr großes System,
da habe ich die Zahlen jetzt nicht so ganz äh im Kopf, das ist ein System, das besteht aus zwei Supermassiven, schwarzen Löchern,
das Schwerere von den beiden hat einige zehn Milliarden, also auch im Vergleich zu dem, was wir im Zentrum unserer Milchstraße haben, ein Kollas.
Und das Leichtere, wenn ich mich nicht irre, hat einige hundert äh Millionen Sonnenmassen und umkreist, die das äh schwerere in der Mitte.
Das Schwere in der Mitte hat eine Aggressionsscheibe, ähm um sich herum, also eine Scheibe von äh Material, sagen wir mal. Und jedes Mal, wenn das leichtere äh,
schwarze Loch da durchfliegt, dann gibt es einen elektromagnetischen Blitz, das kann man dann äh beobachten.
Dieses System wird nun schon seit etwa hundertdreißig Jahren beobachtet. Denkt man natürlich, ne, nur hundertdreißig Jahre, wie geht das den,
da hat man alte Fotografien ausgewertet, von denen ist zum Glück genug gab und man konnte feststellen, dass auch bei diesem System.
Periodendauer des Durchlaufs des leichten, schwarzen Lochs durch die Aggressionsscheibe des größeren schwarzen Lochs abnimm.
Und äh über,
die äh über die Parameter, der äh dieses Systems kann man auch ausrechnen, was da für Gravitationswellen abgestrahlt werden müssen und auch bei diesem System stimmt das, haargenau mit der,
Vorhersage mit der Berechnung überein. Also das gibt es nicht nur ähm.
Im Vergleich dazu möchte man sagen, im kleinen Bereich, äh, der schwarzen Löcher mit einigen Sonnenmassen, sondern eben auch in dem super massiven Bereich. Selbst da hat man Experimentelle, evidenz dafür, dass das alles stimmt.
Albert Einstein kann einen schon fertig machen, ne? Also ich meine, schreibt da so ein paar Formeln auf und äh es bestätigt sich einfach am laufenden Meter auf allen äh Ebenen, gerade was so auf das schwarze Loch, glaube ich, in unserer Milchstraße, äh,
betrifft, gab's ja auch erst jüngst wieder eine Beobachtung von vorbeifliegenden,
äh Objekten, versehenswert, sondern klassifiziert werden, aber so äh wohin man auch schaut, dass wir da mal einfach einmal äh am laufenden Meter die ganze Zeit bestätigt, ein und das andere Mal wie richtig ja an der Stelle,
gelegen ist,
Okay, Nobelpreis für diese Entdeckung des dieser dieses Energieverlustes eines solchen Doppelsternsystems neunzehnhundertdreiundneunzig,
zwei Jahre später ist dann dieser Ort entstanden, an dem wir uns jetzt gerade befin,
Gio sechshundert. Wir haben's ja schon mal erwähnt. Ein Forschungsstandort, wo dann eigentlich das erste Mal in relativ groß so etwas gebaut wurde. Das heißt, dann wollte man's einfach mal wissen,
Wie ist es äh zu diesem Projekt gekommen? Welche Schwierigkeiten musste man denn da überwinden und sowas überhaupt erstmal.
Auf den Weg zugeben.
Der eigentliche Plan war noch eine Nummer größer. Äh nachdem in Garching viele der ähm verbesserung äh Techniken entwickelt wurden und das abzusehen war,
dass das alles in die richtige Richtung geht und dass auch Empfindlichkeiten,
erreicht werden können, äh von denen man annahm, dass man damit Gravitationswellen sehen können wird. War denn war der, die nächste Idee, jetzt bauen wir mal einen richtig großen Orgitationsdetektor.
Und äh eine der Ideen war zum Beispiel.
Unterirdisch ein Gravitationswellendetektor in Dreiecksform zu bauen, Geo nämlich, den Geodetektor,
das sollte im Harz äh im Rammelsberg passieren und war auch schon relativ weit von der Planung her fortgeschritten,
aber die Finanzierung scheiterte dann. Manche sagen, das war 'ne Folge der Wiedervereinigung, der finanziellen Kosten der Wiedervereinigung, andere sagen, nee, das hat damit auch nichts zu tun, ohne dass wer hätte das auch nicht geklappt,
ähm wie auch immer. Es war ein äh Projekt, was.
Ähm die, was letztendlich von der Garchinger Truppe äh getriggert wurde,
in Zusammenarbeit mit den Glasgower Kollegen. In Glasgow in Schottland,
ähm gab es zu der Zeit äh auch schon eine Gruppe, die hatten einen ja ebenfalls ein in der Pharometer im Proteintyp in Tafarometer aufgebaut und die Garchinger Gruppe arbeitete sehr eng mit denen zusammen.
Die hatten auch in den Achtzigern.
Genauer Datum weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr. Ähm einen äh berühmten hundert Stunden Run äh zusammen gemacht. Das heißt, die hatten gemeinsam einhundert Stunden lang Daten aufgenommen und die dann auch auf untersuch.
Womit aufgenommen.
Äh die Daten aufgenommen, womit aufgenommen.
Auch ein Interviewmeter.
Auch in einem interverometer.
In, ja, äh, auch in der elf haben, wegen Struktur, gab es in Glasgow ein Prototyp Winterphänomen.
Warum sollt ihr denn dieses Geo ein Dreieck ein, weil weil man Geodreieck haben wollte?
Das ist ein interessanter Gedanke, den habe ich bisher noch gar nicht gehört.
Ähm nein, also der, der Gedanke war und den verfolgen wir auch beim Einstein Teleskop, wo wir vielleicht noch drauf zu sprechen kommen weiter,
äh dass man versucht hat, die Nutzung der äh unterirdischen Tunnel zu maximieren.
Und äh da schien eine Dreiecksanordnung eben optimal.
Vereine man auf diese Weise, ähm die Dreiecke, ähm also interverometer mit einem Öffnungswinkel von sechzig Grad, äh verschachteln kann sozusagen und die Tunnel dann doppelt nutz.
Mhm. Okay.
Dieses dieser Vorschlag, ein drei Kilometer großen Detektor unterirdisch zu bauen, scheiterte also.
Drei Kilometer Schenkellänge oder dann insgesamt, also.
Drei Kilometer Schenkeldenke. Gleichzeitig ist Dreieck mit drei Kilometern. Das wäre der Vorschlag gewesen. Ja, das war der Vorschlag.
Dieser Vorschlag scheiterte und nun war die Überlegung, was macht man stattdessen.
Und äh dann wurde gesagt, okay, dann gehen wir nicht einen Schritt von dreißig Meter auf drei Kilometer, sondern machen erstmal einen Schritt um eine Größenordnung, bauen also ein dreihundert Meter großes Interverometer.
Da wurden dann auch verschiedene Standorte für ausgeguckt äh und äh hier in Route bei Saarstäd ähm wurde dann ein Platz gefunden. Der,
von der Geografie des Landes, also es ist hier flach genug, der Untergrund ist gut geeignet. Ähm es befindet sich zum äh Gutteil auf staatlichem Gelände, Universitätsgelände beziehungsweise Tierärztliche Hochschule.
Und soviel dann die Entscheidung, das hier zu bauen.
Mich wundert es gerade, dass es so schwierig ist, so ein Ort zu finden, wo man mal äh sich ein paar hundert Meter irgendwo entlang strecken kann, so man das ja jetzt auch nicht
ist ja nur eine Längenausdehnung und nicht so sehr eine Ausdehnung in die Breite. Also man braucht ja nicht einen sechshundert mal sechshundert Meter großes Areal, sondern eben nur so zweimal sechshunder,
quasi in Feldweg äh Dimensionen, was was macht es so schwierig, so einen Ort zu finden.
Es ist nicht besonders schwierig, so ein Ort zu finden, aber es ist natürlich eine finanzielle Frage,
für dieses Gelände bezahlen wir relativ wenig Miete. Generell ist es keine überwältigende Schwierigkeiten, geeignetes Gelände von speziell zweimal dreihundert Meter, wie wir es damals gesucht hatten zu finden.
Johanna, die Entscheidung viel, dass hier äh in Route zu bauen und war eben ein Versuch der beiden Gruppen äh im Glasgow und in Garching.
Trotz der finanziellen Schwierigkeiten.
Gravitationswellen, Detektor zu bauen, der mit den, zu derselben Zeit, geplanten Detektoren, Wirgo und Leigo.
Drei, beziehungsweise vier Kilometer Armlänge äh ebenbürtig sein könnte.
Diese ganzen Standorte wurde wurden parallel schon angedacht.
Die ganze Standorte wurden parallel angedacht, das ist richtig.
Mhm. Aber dann wurden's ja dann sechshundert Meter äh anstatt dreihundert, weil einmal einfach den Platz hatte oder.
Man hatte den Platz. Äh man stellte insbesondere bei der Planung fest, dass ähm das hat auch mit dem Konzept zu tun, was für das Vakuumsystem verfolgt haben,
das bei einer äh Vergrößerung auf sechshundert Kilometer. Die kosten nur äh sechshundert Meter, Entschuldigung.
Kilometer wäre da hätten wir andere Schwierigkeiten in der Tat, also äh bei einer Vergrößerung auf sechshundert Meter. Die Kosten in einem Rahmen, den wir noch finanzieren können,
steigen können. Und so sind wir dann auf sechshundert Meter gegangen, sechshundert Meter, war dann auch das Maximum, was wir auf diesem Gelände unterbringen konnten.
Schauen wir uns doch mal an, was jetzt hier eigentlich genau steht. So und im Prinzip, das klang ja schon an, die Technologie, die hier zum Einsatz kommt.
Nicht nur im Wesentlichen, das, was auch in den anderen äh Standorten ankommt, sondern hier ist sie vor allem auch entwickelt worden.
Hier ist ein Gutteil der Technik entwickelt worden,
was den wesentlichen Empfindlichkeitssteigerungsschritt von der ersten Generation, also Leigo und Wirgo zur zweiten Generation Advanced Ligh und Advanced ausgemacht hat.
Das das hängt äh eben auch mit der Größe von Geo sechshundert zusammen,
ähm um eine vergleichbare Empfindlichkeit wie die größeren Detektoren erreichen zu können, mussten wir natürlich fortgeschrittene Technologien einbauen,
die von den anderen Konsortien als noch nicht ausgereift genug empfunden wurden. Das ist natürlich auch eine finanzielle Frage.
Dass in den größeren Detektoren, die auch entsprechend teurer sind, äh, einzubauen, birgt dann natürlich auch ein größeres, finanzielles Risiko im Fall, dass nicht funktionierens.
Hier sind wir also.
Ähm gewissermaßen ein höheres Risiko eingegangen. Wir waren uns da sehr zuversichtlich, weil wir einige dieser Techniken auch in Garching am Prototypen schon getestet hatten.
Einer der Unterschiede ist zum Beispiel, dass äh in der ersten Generation von Leigo, die Spiegel als Einfachpendel, also als eine einfache Pendelstufe aufgehängt wurden.
Ähm während wir hier unsere Spiegel als Dreifachpendel aufgehängt haben.
Lass uns dann gleich mal äh im Detail auf die auf die ganze äh Technik eingehen. Ich wollte nur mal kurz äh festhalten. Also,
Geo sechshundert ist auch gedacht gewesen, als ein Ort, an dem die Technologie, zur Messung, als solche, überhaupt erstmal getestet wird. Es ging nicht primär dadrum,
hier jetzt wirklich mit dem Ziel mit an diesem Ort wird letzten Endes auch die erste Gravitationswelle gemessen.
Na, es war schon, es war schon eine Mischung. Ähm man muss sich auch vor Augen halten in zu dem Zeitpunkt als GO sechshundert geplant wurde
ähm hatte, waren die Vorstellungen über die Stärke von Gravitationswellen, zu erwartende Stärke von Gravitationswellen noch nicht so ausgereift wie heute.
Hatte ähm sehr vagevorstellungen über die Populationen der verschiedenen Quellen, also über die Häufigkeit, der zu erwartenden Ereignisse.
In den Achtzigern zum Beispiel ähm erwartete man von Supernova Explosion sehr, sehr viel stärkere Gravitationswähler, als das heute der Fall ist.
Und als äh wir mit Geo sechshundert angefangen haben und auch noch lange Zeit in den Bau hinein, äh hofften wir schon, äh dass wir Gravitationswellen äh detektieren würden.
Wie konnte man sich da so verschätzen, wenn wenn man die äh wenn sich die.
Allgäuer Rhythmen, also die, die Gleichung von Einstein im Prinzip, die ganze Zeit so bewiesen haben und man das auch schon äh an diesem Doppelsternsystem hat, nachmessen können, dann hätte man doch,
würde ich mir jetzt vorstellen, könnte man doch relativ klar sagen, was bei so einer Supernova passiert oder hat man dann einfach die Energie dieser Ereignisse als solcher überschätz.
Also bei einem Doppelsternsystem, sagen wir mal aus zwei Neutronenstern oder aus zwei schwarzen Löchern, es ist einfach, sich die Stärke des Signals auszurechnen,
wenn man alles kennt, wenn man die Entfernung kennt, wenn man die Massen kennt.
Was man allerdings nicht wusste, was man bisher äh immer noch nicht sehr gut weiß,
ist, wie viele davon gibt es denn in welcher Entfernung? Wie viele? Neutronen, Sternen, Paare, gibt es in unserer Milchstraße, ähm wie häufig werden die miteinander verschmelzen,
Da gibt's Abschätzungen, das ist etwa alle hundert Jahre. Pro Milchstraßen, Equivalent der Fall ist. Äh in der Milchstraße würde GO sechshundert sowas auch sehen können.
Ähm aber außerhalb nicht. Bei Super Nove ist das deutlich schwieriger. So eine super Nova ist ja ein äh wenn wenn ein äh massiver Stern das Ende seines Lebens erreicht und der äh,
der der Brennprozess dann aufhört und der Kern kollabiert. Ähm,
werden sehr, sehr viele neue Trainers freigesetzt, die dann praktisch die ganze Hülle wegblasen.
Das ist ein höllisch komplizierter Prozess. Die Simulation, die dafür durchgeführt werden müssen, um die Gravitationswellen, Signale, vorherzusagen, sind sehr, sehr aufwendig und sehr komplex und hängen,
auch von unbekannten Parametern ab.
Das heißt, da haben sich im Laufe der Zeit, ähm, in der die Simulation besser wurden, auch die Vorhersagen stark geändert,
und auch jetzt noch sind die äh vorhersagen nicht sehr die Stimmen noch nicht sehr gut überein. Das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, welche,
welche Prozesse man mitnimmt, ähm von welchem man annimmt, dass sie dominieren,
Also von super Nova, äh Gravitationsfällen, sie, man weiß immer noch nicht genau, wie die Gravitationswellen, Signatur, einer super Nova Explosion aussehen wird. Was ist natürlich umso interessanter, macht sie mal zu beobachten.
Da dürft ihr alle schon richtig mit den Hufen geschaut haben, als äh der Sternwettergeholze äh dunkel geworden ist und dachten so, kommt jetzt die Supernova.
Äh gewesen. Ich glaube, hat sich jetzt rausgestellt, es sind nur extrem große Sonnenflecken, die dazu geführt haben, dass diese Helligkeitsänderung sich.
Er hat sich jetzt ja auch wieder erholt.
Hat sich auch wieder erholt, genau und äh dementsprechend muss äh das Ereignis dann auch verschoben werden. Okay, gut, also man man war guter Hoffnung, aber man konnte es eben nicht äh einschätzen, man hätte schon eine,
Chance, dass wenn jetzt so äh etwas bei uns in der Milchstraße stattfindet,
äh dass dann auch hier zu messen, aber es passiert halt einfach relativ selten, beziehungsweise man wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt zumindest noch nicht, oder weiß es vielleicht auch heute noch nicht so richtig, wie äh häufig das ist. Das,
ändert sich jetzt wahrscheinlich.
Mit den Gravitationsfällen, Beobachtungen, die wir jetzt gemacht haben, haben wir natürlich eine wesentlich bessere Vorstellung über die Population, also über die dichten, äh, der.
Dieser dieser äh Paare von äh Sternen und der Ereignisse der Verschmelzungsereignisse.
Gut, dann schauen wir doch mal, was jetzt hier eigentlich genau gebaut wurde. Also,
ich hab's ja schon äh gesagt, wir sind hier äh auf dem Acker rundherum wächst äh viel Gemüse, Windräder drehen sich und ja, hier sind so ein paar,
äh Hütten, das alles sehr unpräzisiös äh gebaut und,
es gibt einen zentralen Bereich von dem aus, dann zwei Arme eben im neunzig Grad oder ich glaube, fast neunzig Grad äh Winkel, wenn ich richtig äh unterrichtet bin.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also, äh, wenn man ins Detail guckt, dann stellt man hier an vielen Enten und Ecken fest, äh, dann sieht man die Finanzschwierigkeiten an vielen Ecken und Enden,
also auch der, du sagtest unprätentiöse Bau ist natürlich 'ne Folge der Finanzierung,
wir mussten schon sehr drauf achten, dass wir alles so mäßig wie nur irgend möglich bauen und trotzdem,
da, wo es wirklich drauf ankommt, dann das die beste Technologie einbauen, die möglich ist. Die Gebäude.
Dann braucht man einfach nur eine Hülle drum rum, die einen vor dem Wetter schützt. Äh deswegen äh sind das eben Container äh artige Strukturen,
ein bisschen in die Erde eingelassen,
damit äh der Wind ein bisschen weniger dran rüttelt, damit wir von den Umwelteinflüssen ein kleines bisschen geschützt sind, aber auch die,
die Gräben hier in den die Vakuumrohre für die Leserstrahlen, also die die arme langlaufen,
hast du ja auch gesehen, dass es mit Spundwänden gerammt und mit Wellblech abgedeckt, also auch alles so zu so niedrigen Kosten wie möglich. Und auch diese vierundneunzig Komma drei fünf Grad, die der Winkel,
ist, ähm, der ist auch eine Folge der Finanzierung,
Es gibt hier zwei Feldwege, die eben zufällig diesen Winkel zueinander haben und die Empfindlichkeit weicht von einem Gravitationswellendetektor ist bei neunzig Grad, maximal, aber weich dann nur sehr, sehr,
langsam davon ab. Und so müssen wir eben für den Nordabend hier weniger Miete bezahlen. Das ist der einzige Grund dafür, dass es vierundneunzig Komma drei fünf Grad sind.
Ansonsten hätte man die Wege noch etwas äh verlegen und anpassen müssen und mehr Land äh anbieten müssen.
Okay, also wir haben hier dieses äh zentrale Gebäude und dort findet die ganze äh Lasermagie äh statt und die,
Leser, äh werden dann halt auf diese sechshundert Meter lange,
Stricke äh geschickt eben in diesem grob neunzig äh Gradwinkel. Das ist ja das äh Prinzip sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen. Man man streckt quasi seine, seine Arme in zwei.
Richtungen aus und geht davon aus, dass wenn jetzt eine Gravitationswelle durch die Erde walkt, dann kommt die ja,
von irgendwoher, die kann von oben von unten von links von rechts äh kommen, so oder so, wenn man also seine Schüler so weit in unterschiedliche Richtungen ausstreckt,
dann wird es so sein, dass diese Welle an der einen Stelle irgendwie früher ankommt als an der anderen.
Wenn's nicht genau wirklich von unten.
Das stimmt im Prinzip, ist aber äh im Blick auf einen einzelnen Gravitationswellen Detektor äh irrelevant. Die Laufzeitunterschiede da sind sehr, sehr gering.
Das wird interessant, wenn wir über die Erde verteilte Detektoren betrachten,
Und das ist genau das Prinzip, wie wir dann auch die Richtung der Gravitationswelle bestimmen.
Das heißt, äh, wenn eine Gravitationswerte aus einer bestimmten Richtung kommt, dann kommt sie meine Fägen bei dem einen Leigo-Detektor zuerst an, beim anderen ein kleines bisschen später und in Europa, weil Geo sechshundert oder bei Wirgo dann noch ein bisschen später.
Ja gut, aber um die Welle überhaupt erstmal zu spüren, ist es sozusagen auch das Prinzip, dass die Auswirkungen der Welle auf beide Armen unterschiedlich.
Nein, nein, also das ist eine äh direkte Folge der Gravitationswelle, eine Gravitationswelle ist eine Quatropolwelle und wenn die jetzt zum Beispiel von oben von direkt oben auf GO sechshundert fällt und die richtige Orientierung kann, die richtige Polarisation nennen wir das.
Und der Ostarm wird länger, dann wird zur gleichen Zeit der Nordarm kürzer. Also es sind differenzieller Effe.
Aber instantan überall, wenn die direkt von oben kommt.
Ah, okay, gut, das hat sich dann verwechselt mit dieser äh Ausrichtungsgeschichte. Okay, eine Quadropolwelle, was muss man sich darunter vorstellen.
Also ähm im Gegensatz äh zu einem elektrischen Feld, was ein Diepol ist, ähm was eben einfach da dran liegt, dass es zwei verschiedene Ladungen, positive und negative Ladungen gibt, ähm bei einer Masse gibt es nur positive Masse,
ähm da gibt es dann kein, kein Depol, Charakter, da kann eine Welle keinen Depot haben und dass das niedrigste Moment, ein Quadropol Moment, also ähm.
Wenn wenn wie ich eben beschrieben habe, wenn die Gravitationsfälle in der einen Richtung den Raum dehnt, dann staucht sie ihn in der anderen Richtung.
Und wo kommt das Quandro dann her? Also was ist dann der Vierfachfaktor.
Äh ja.
Okay, was was finden wir also jetzt? In Geo sechshundert, genau. Also, es ist ja im Prinzip irgendwo wird ein Laser losgeschickt und,
diese beiden Schenkel, ne? Aber damit dir diesen We
äh findet, das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur so ein Laser und dann geht er in die eine Richtung und wieder zurück und fertig, sondern das ist ja ein
relativ komplexes Gebilde von mehreren Spiegeln. Es geht irgendwie äh x mal im Kreis und vorne und hinten. Um die Ecke äh bis es dann wirklich,
auf diese Reise äh.
Genau, können wir ja mal versuchen, zu verfolgen.
Genau, fangen wir doch äh mal vorne an.
Genau, es fängt ja erstmal mit dem Laser an. Also bevor der Laserstrahl äh los, sausen kann, müssen wir ja erstmal erzeugen,
und da war auf dem Weg vom äh Garchinger Prototypen bis heute äh auch viel Arbeit zu tun. Ä,
der äh Garchinger Prototyp und auch der Glasgauer Prototyp äh wurden seinerzeit mit Argonionen Laser. Das waren äh gewissermaßen die Dinosaurier der Laserwelt,
das waren Laser im sichtbaren, typischerweise grün, hat man eine grüne Wellenlänge verwendet,
ähm und um einige Watt an Laserleistung zu erzeugen, musste man typischerweise etwa dreißig Kilowatt reinstecken. Also waren schöne Energievernichter.
Die Stabilität der Laserstrahlen war verglichen mit heute auch sehr, sehr schlecht, also,
äh die Wellenlänge war äh bei weitem nicht so stabil wie heute. Die Leistung, die Leserleistung war bei weitem nicht so stabil.
In Hannover wurden damals schon Laser andere Laserfestkörperlaser entwickelt Laser, die arbeiten beinah,
Infraroten wählen, denn im nah Infraroten war tausendvierundsechzig Nanometer, also Grün zum Beispiel wäre, sagen wir mal fünfhundertdreißig Nanometer.
Ähm und,
die Laser, die in Hannover entwickelt wurden, ähm haben wir dann auch äh in GO sechshundert eingesetzt. Alle Gravitationsfällen, Detektoren laufen heutzutage mit äh Jagläsern aus Hannover.
Aus Hannover heißt dann aus aus dem Albert Einstein Institut oder aus einem anderen Bereich.
Ist eine Zusammenarbeit des Laserzentrums Hannover und dem Albert Einstein Institut.
Und die, also diese, äh, diese Laser sind heutzutage äh sehr, sehr viel stabiler,
als die äh die Argonion Leser, was damals waren,
im, also im Bezug auf ähm Wellenlängen, Stabilität, Leistung, Stabilität, ähm auch äh die Pointing stabil, quasi Richtung, in die da äh Laser, Strahl zeigt.
Und auch äh lassen sich heutzutage höhere Leistungen erreichen. Diese, diese hochstabilen Laser.
Bauen wir in Hannover heute mit einer Leistung von zweihundert Watt. Das klingt jetzt, wenn man an Materialbearbeitung denkt, nicht allzu schrecklich viel, wo Kilowatt Lasergang und Gäbe sind, aber äh die unterscheiden sich in der Stabilität erheblich.
Diese Laser,
werden dann also ähm in Richtung in der Parometer losgeschickt, aber stellt sich raus, dass äh speziell auch die äh die Lagefluktuation, also die Richtung in dieser Laserstrahl zeigt noch zu sehr fluktuieren,
Das heißt, die müssen erstmal noch weiter gereinigt, wie wir dazu sagen werden. Wir schicken.
Sehr fluktuieren heißt, würde man sie einfach jetzt ohne sie noch weiter anzufassen, einfach so nehmen, dann würden sie gar nicht richtig im Ziel landen können oder zu sehr hin und her schwanken und man könnte nichts präziser einstellen.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man das sehen würde, dass der Laserstrahl nicht in die richtige Richtung zeigt, aber äh bei den extrem messgenauigkeiten, die wir erreichen, würde das die Messgenauigkeit limitieren.
Das heißt, wir schicken die äh durch optische Resonatoren durch. Also ähm wir reflektieren den Laserstrahl äh immer im Kreisraum sozusagen,
und das, das stabilisiert den, das stabilisiert den rauskommen, den Laserstrahl beschicken, den durch einen optischen Resonator durch.
Warum stabilisiert das, wenn man den im Kreis schi.
Weil ähm die, die Schwankungen rausgemittelt werden.
Also die ähm es wird nur ein Laserstrahl, Transmittiert, der zu äh.
Der zu dem Resonator sagen wir mal.
Weil, weil, weil alles, was sozusagen nicht nicht genau auf der Linie, die man haben will, auf der Richtung, auf den, die man haben will, ist, würde dann sozusagen irgendwann rausfliegen. Sozusagen. Weggespiegelt werden.
Sozusagen, ja, also, also, wenn wir uns das mal als zwei spielen, das, das sind tatsächlich drei Spiegel,
äh Resonanz vorgenommen, aber wenn wir uns das mal als ein zweispiegelresonator vorstellen,
und der Strahl, saust immer zwischen diesen Spiegeln hin und her. Nur was genau zu den, zu der Ausrichtung der Spiegel passt, wird dann letztendlich auch transmetiert und der ganze Rest wird reflektiert oder geht anderswo.
Mhm, okay.
Und auf diese Weise kann man also die Laserstrahlen noch weiter stabilisieren.
Noch weiter, weiß ich ja, bündeln das richtige Wort ist, aber.
Nee bündeln.
Man bündelt nicht, aber alles das, was nicht so in die Richtung geht, die man jetzt wirklich genau haben will, würde in diesem Prozess einfach rausgeschleudert werden quasi.
Speziell alles das, was variiert, was zeitlich variiert, das ist das, was uns am meisten stört. Das wollen wir rausfiltern. Wir wollen ein zeitlich, extrem stabilen Laserstrahl haben.
Wir wir messen im Augenblick, also die die äh Gravitationswellendetektoren, die wir im Augenblick betreiben, messen, so sagen wir mal, von dreißig Hertz bis einige Kilo Herz.
Das heißt, wenn der Laserstrahl jetzt so ganz langsam bis ganz kleines bisschen hin und her zeigern würde, das würde uns nicht weiter stören. Weil die Störungen, die er verursacht dann bei einer zu niedrigen Frequenz sind.
Aber in diesen Messbereich in den Messbereich, in dem wir nachher Gravitationswellen detektieren wollen, muss der Laser so stabil sein, wie nur irgend möglich. Er darf nicht hin und her zeigern,
weil das letztendlich dann ein äh Signal auf unserem Fotodetektor ganz am Ende der Kette durch die wir jetzt gleich gehen,
auf dem Fotodetektor ganz am Ende würde das ein Signal erzeugen und wir könnten nicht sagen, was ist denn das jetzt? Äh wackelte der Laser da in der Richtung, ein kitzelkleines bisschen,
oder er hat die Leserleistung ein kleines bisschen sich geändert. Wir sehen nur das Signal an der Fotodiode und denken, hm, da ist wohl irgendwas passiert, war es jetzt eine Gravitationswelle oder war es was anderes? Und deswegen müssen wir von vorne rein,
alle Störquellen, alles, was dort ein Signal erzeugen könnte. So sehr minimieren, wie wir das noch können.
Okay, also optischer Resonator im Prinzip, das Licht wird die ganze Zeit in drei Spiegeln immer wieder im Kreis äh herumgeschickt, aber wenn's dann die ganze Zeit im Kreis äh herumfliegt, wie kriegt man's dann wieder raus.
Na ja, also äh wir haben einen Spiegel von diesen drei Spiegeln, haben zwei Spiegel eine etwas höhere äh Transmission. Der dritte Spiegel reflektiert so gut es geht,
und wir schicken also durch einen Spiegel das Licht in diesen optischen Resonantor rein und das kommt dann durch den zweiten Spiegel wieder raus.
Also quasi so ein halt durchlässiger Spiegel.
Halbdurchlässig ist. Der falsche Ausdruckteil durchlässig wird.
Teildurchlässig, okay. Gut. Das heißt, man nimmt immer nur wieder äh ein bisschen von dem, aber durch diese permanente Reflexion staut es sich sozusagen auch äh die ganze Zeit auf.
Genau und genau, es schaukelt sich, es schaukelt sich innen drinnen auf in diesem äh optischen Resonator, also wir nennen den Boden Cleaner, ähm weil der das Laserlicht, die Lesermode reinig,
das schaut dieses Licht schaukelt sich in dem auf. Ähm dort haben wir eine deutlich höhere Leistung als wir reinschicken,
und äh entsprechend der Transmission von dem Auskoppelspiegel koppeln wir eben immer einen gewissen Teil.
Bezeichnet die Mode genau, also was welche Eigenschaft des Lasers äh ist das jetzt sozusagen die Frequenz oder.
Nein, widersprechen, äh, da über über räumliche Moden, ähm, ein, ein Laserstrahl ist, äh der hat, der hat kein rechteckiges Profil. Ähm, also wenn ich,
wenn ich mir die intensität eines Laserstrahls quer zu seiner Ausbreitungsrichtung angucke, dann ist der normale Laserstrahl rund,
aber wenn ich da jetzt einen Querschnitt der Intensität mache, dann ist das eine Gausverteilung, also eine Gausstückkurve.
In der Mitte und.
Das meiste in der Mitte und fällt dann äh zum Rand hinab, ganz genau. Äh,
Und das ist eine, ähm, das ist eine Strahlform, die äh in einem optischen Resonator mit fairischen Spiegeln stabil ist. Nach nach einem Umlauf,
wenn das also an einem gekrümmten Spiegel reflektiert wird, nochmal an einem gekunden Spiegelreflektiert wird,
dann ist das äh ein äh eine selbsterhaltende Form. Das heißt, eine, eine eigene Mode, wie wir das dann in dieses Resonators.
Das ist letztendlich auch der Grund, warum man mit einem, in einer solchen Anordnung die Laserstrahlen filtern kann, mit dem man die reinigen kann.
Durch den Modkliener. Okay, das heißt, das Ding ist jetzt, äh, einmal aufgeschaukelt, äh, verstärkt und dann äh,
gesäubert, äh, äh, worden, alles, alles, was hier nicht mit der Mode geht, sozusagen,
fliegt raus, steckt ein strenges Moderegime schon gleich
am Anfang und jetzt hat man ein gratis Lasersignal, was zumindest schon mal das Versprechen hat
weniger Störungen zu erzeugen, denn Störungen wird's im laufenden äh Prozess noch eine ganze Menge äh geben, zumindest potenzielle Störungen
Wo geht's jetzt äh weiter.
Der nächste Schritt ist dann den Strahl aufzuweiten. Äh also wir haben bisher einen Strahl in den Mordkindern, hat der Strahl ungefähr ein Durchmesser von einem Millimeter, sagen wir mal,
ähm die auf aufgrund dieser ähm gaußischen Strahlformen ähm.
Ähm erfährt ein Laserstrahl, aber eine, eine Verbreitung,
Je kleiner, der Strahl ist hier kleiner, ich mit dem Strahldurchmesser anfängt, desto divergenter ist der Strahl,
Also ähm ein ein Laserstrahl kann nicht vollkommen kollimiert sein. Das kennt man auch von dem Laserpointer, wenn man relativ nah dran ist an dem Laserpoint, da ist der Strahl relativ klein, wenn ich den aber zum Beispiel über zehn Meter,
auf einer Wandschicke ist er schon ein bisschen größer.
Also der Kegel der Licht.
Der Lichtkegel und der Öffnungswinkel des Lichtkegels hängt davon ab, wie schmal der ist. Nun wollen wir den Laserstrahl aber über große Entfernungen schicken,
bei GO sechshundert, die sechshundert Meter oder vier Kilometer Balaigo, das heißt, wir müssen den erstmal aufweiten, damit der Lichtkegelöffnungswinkel nicht zu groß ist, sonst würde da hinten äh überhaupt nicht mehr auf den Spiegel passen.
Das nächste ist also ein Teleskop. Aufhaltungsteleskop. Und dann wären wir soweit den Strahl ins Intervermeter zu schicken, das heiß.
Breit ist er denn dann.
Äh im Fall von Geo sechshundert ist er dann zwei Zentimeter im Durchmesser.
Okay. Und man sieht den ja nicht, weil das ist, wir reden jetzt von einem Infraro.
Wir reden von einem Infrarotenstrahl, das heißt immer dann, wenn wir den sehen wollen, dann müssen wir entweder mit Kameras hingucken oder mit Infrarotvieren oder mit äh wenn der Strahl zugänglich ist, mit Infrarotsichtkarten. Das ein bisschen lä.
Man so reinhält und so.
Man so reinhält und dann dann leuchten die so ein bisschen auf, genau. Ja.
Wir sind nicht ganz ungefährlich. Also äh war ja kurz in dem äh Raum, da geht dann ohne Schutzbrille äh nichts, weil natürlich diese Lasermengen, die da unterwegs sind, potenziell schon gefährlich sein können fürs Augenlicht zumindest.
Potenziell ist das gefährlich. Ähm das ist natürlich alles eingehaust und äh entsprechend sicher gemacht, aber,
bei gerade auch bei Infrarotem Licht wäre man natürlich auch nicht würde man nicht vor der Gefahr gewarnt, dadurch, dass man im Licht sieht.
Ähm dass das Infrarote-Licht äh würde, das Auge schädigen ohne, dass man man es sieht und deswegen sind wir da eben entsprechend vorsichtig.
Also jetzt haben wir zwei Zentimeter.
Jetzt haben wir zwei Zentimeter Strahl, den können wir jetzt äh in die Interferometerarme schicken. Dazu haben wir da ein Strahlteiler,
und ähm der Strahlteiler ist jetzt das erste Element des eigentlichen Kerninterverometers.
Wenn man jetzt Längenänderungen der Arme in dem äh genannten Bereich, also mit einer äh relativen Änderung von zehn Uhr minus einundzwanzig messen will,
dann äh dürfen die optischen Elemente natürlich nicht wackeln, wenn jetzt äh die Endspiegel oder auch der Strahlteiler entsprechend wackeln würde,
dann äh hätte man ein Signal und könnte nicht mehr sagen, kommt das jetzt durch das Boden wackeln oder von der Gravitationswelle.
Der Strahltaler ist letztlich so ein Prisma.
Der Strahlteiler ist ist gewissermaßen eine Scheibe. Eine Quarzglasscheibe. In unserem Fall sechsundzwanzig Zentimeter im Durchmesser und äh sechs, acht Zentimeter di.
Warum ist er so groß, wenn der Strahl so klein ist.
Das hat damit zu tun, dass äh der Strahl an der Vorderseite dieses äh Glasklotzes, dieses Glaszillen, das ist ein Glasscheibe,
geteilt wird, fünfzig fünfzig, genau genommen ist es nicht ganz fünfzig, fünfzig, im Fall von Geo sechshundert, aus technischen Gründen ist achtundvierzig, zweiundfünfzig, dann läuft der eine Strahl, also in unserem Fall in Richtung Norden, der reflektierte,
und der transmittierte Strahl läuft in Richtung Osten, aber nun hat diese Glasscheibe natürlich auch noch eine Rückseite.
Und egal wie viel Mühe man sich gibt mit einer entsprechenden Beschichtung, um zu vermeiden, dass da noch Licht reflektiert wird. Ein kleines bisschen wird immer reflektiert,
in unserem Fall sind es wie viel sind das denn jetzt überhaupt? Ich glaube fünfzig PPM fünfzig.
Und um diese Reflexe noch unter Kontrolle zu halten und dann ordentlich blocken, beziehungsweise auch verwenden zu können, muss der Strahltaler groß genug sein.
Okay, bist du einfach eine technische Anforder.
Einzelne technische Anforderung um die parasitären Strahlen, die da noch reflektiert werden, noch kontrollieren zu könn,
Da haben wir also diese zwei Strahlen ähm und schicken die jetzt über die möglichst lange Entfernung. Sechshundert Meter entfernt, auf Spiegel am Ende dieser langen Arme, die natürlich auch wieder aufgehängt sind, u,
sie von der Seismischen, Bewegung zu isolieren. Also das,
das Prinzip, die Spiegel, die die Bodenbewegung von den Spiegeln fernzuhalten, ist ein sehr einfaches,
Man hängt den Spiegel als Pendel auf. Und wenn ich von einem Pendel ähm stellen wir uns mal vor, wir halten ein Jojo in der Hand.
Wenn ich den,
Faden, langsam, hin und her bewegen, erfolgreich. Jojo, natürlich. Wenn ich den Faden mit einer bestimmten Frequenz hin und her bewege, dann ist es wie eine Schaukel und äh wir haben einen Resonanzeffekt, das Jojo unten bewegt sich viel mehr, als ich meine Hand bewege.
Schaukelt sich auf.
Schaukelt sich auf. Irgendwo habe ich also in Resonanz.
Bei höheren Frequenzen, wenn ich meine Hand ganz schnell hin und her bewege, dann bewegt sich zwar der Aufhängepunkt, aber aufgrund seiner Massenträgheit bleibt die aufgehängte Masse,
an einem Ort. Ich habe also eine starke Unterdrückung der Bewegung von meinem Aufhängepunkt.
Und genau das ist das Prinzip, was wir verwenden, um die Spiegel, das in der Pharometers von der Bodenbildungsisolierung. Wir benutzen Pendel,
die horizontale Richtung interessiert uns natürlich am meisten, aber wir müssen auch auf die vertikale Bewegung ein bisschen aufpassen, deswegen,
werden die Pendel alle an äh solchen Blattfedern äh aufgehängt, dass wir also auch eine vertikale Isolation haben.
Da haben wir jetzt eigentlich äh eine Komponente haben wir vergessen, die zwar jetzt nicht äh optisch äh äh direkt einwirkt, aber das Licht muss sich ja auch irgendwo drin,
ausbreiten. Und das sind ja dann so dicke fette Rohre. Ich weiß nicht, so halber Meter Durchmesser, wenn,
äh okay, sechzig Zentimeter, äh, aus, äh, Metall, auch nicht aus,
äh nicht irgendein Stahlgemisch, sondern auch eins, was speziell für diese Bedingungen geeignet äh ist.
Ja, wir verwenden für die äh, für die Vakuumsysteme der Gravitationswellen, Edelstahl, ähm, der ähm sich mit ähm,
der bietet gute Voraussetzungen, um ein ultrahoch Vakuum zu schaffen.
Im Fall von Geo sechshundert sind wir da auch einen speziellen Weg gegangen,
wir wollten eine hochqualitative Edelstahlsorte, die sich durch eine geringe Ausgasung von äh Gasen ähm speziell Wasserstoff,
auszeichnet, äh die gut formbar ist,
Widerstandsfähig gegen die widrigen Umstände in unseren Gräben, wo wir das Vakuumrohr entlang gelegt haben ist,
Und äh wir haben uns da für ein sehr ähm Korrosionsfesten Edelstahl entschieden,
der ist äh entsprechend teuer und so haben wir bei Geo sechshundert, das Vakuumor sehr dünnwandig gemacht,
dass äh Vakuum, Rohr selbst, hat nur eine Dicke von null Komma acht Millimetern,
wenn ich da einfach ein äh Rohr mit sechshundert Millimeter Durchmesser nehmen würde, so dünnwandig und das evakuiere, dann würde der äußere Luftdruck das einfach zusammen quetschen.
Deswegen äh haben wir das in Längsrichtung gewählt. Das heißt äh, es ist jetzt ein Wellrohr.
Mit einer Wand äh dicke unter einem Millimeter, aber dadurch die Wellung sehr stabil äh gegen den Luftdruck. Also man kann, man kann auch durchaus äh,
auf das Rohr draufklettern, falls das nötig ist, das ist äh ist außerordentlich stabil.
Die Folge davon ist, dass wir ein kostengünstiges äh Vakuumrohr,
herstellen konnten, was es uns dann ja auch erlaubt hat, um von dreihundert Metern auf sechshundert Meter, die äh maximale Größe auf diesem Gelände zu gehen, was die Länge von Geo sechshundert angeht und das hat sich äh auch als sehr langlebig herausgestellt.
Diese Vakuum ist immer da, das wird nicht irgendwie mal bei Bedarf äh hergestellt, sondern da ist halt einfach möglichst nichts drin. Also wie wie.
Wie viel Vakuum oder wie wenig Materie ist denn da noch drin? Also gibt's da ja auch verschiedene Abstufungen.
Um ja, also das das Vakuum wurde in der Tat äh zu Beginn einmal hergestellt,
das ist insofern ein bisschen aufwendig als,
die Wassermoleküle, die in der Luftfeuchtigkeit vorhanden sind, dazu tendigeren sehr fest an der Stahloberfläche zu haften,
und dann äh im Laufe der Zeit äh von dort ausgasen und für lange, lange Zeit das Vakuum ruinieren würden, bei den Drucken, von denen wir reden. Das heißt, wir mussten zu Anfang einmal das Vagum System ausheizen.
Dazu wurde das gesamte äh GO sechshundert Rohr, also eins Komma zwei Kilometer in Steinwolle eingepackt. Äh das haben seinerzeit studentische Hilfskräfte gemacht,
die erstaunlicherweise im Rückblick eine sehr verklärte Sicht auf dieser Arbeit haben und es sehr genossen haben, die Gemeinschaf.
Äh und dann haben wir Strom durchgeschickt. Sechshundert Ampere durch das ganze Rohr und es auf die Weise auf zweihundertfünfzig Grad aufgeheizt. Was den äh was den Wasserfilm, die Monolage, Wasser dann von den Wänden äh wegtreibt,
das äh haben wir einmal gemacht und seitdem wurde das Vakuumsystem, wo das Vakuum aufrecht erhalten.
Seit wie lange.
Äh, wann war das erste Mal? Evakuiert, äh, siebenundneunzig, glaube ich.
Ja, äh das, es gibt eine einzige Ausnahme. Wir hatten am Nordrhein ein kleines Leck, ein etwa fünfzig mikrometer großes Loch,
da hatte es sich ein Marder auf dem Vakuumrohr in der Nähe des Zentralhauses gemütlich gemacht im Winter, weil es da ein bisschen kuschliger war, als anderswo draußen,
ähm und hat aber dann mit seinen Exkrementen äh das äh ein kleines Loch in das Vakuumrohr gefressen sozusagen.
Findet man denn sowas.
Das kann man mit Lektests durch äh Helium, Gas, man ist, man kann,
massenselektiv, das Gas im Vakuumsystem untersuchen.
Und dann von außen Helium, was in der Atmosphäre natürlicherweise nicht vorkommt, weil es zu leicht ist in den Weltraum entfleucht, äh kann man es von außen mit Helium beaufschlagen und wenn man das Segmentweise macht, kann man so ein Leck relativ schnell finden,
Also fünfzig Mikrometer ist ein, ist ein Loch, das ist kein Leck mehr, das ist schon Loch. Das haben wir relativ schnell gefunden.
Und äh haben letztendlich dann, um das zu reparieren, das Nordrohr mit trockenem Stickstoff, mit hoch reinem äh Stickstoff geflutet und dann geschweiß.
Also das war das einzige Mal, dass äh das Nordrohr äh nicht unter Vakuum war.
Müsste in der Vakuumprozess nochmal komplett wiederholt werden oder.
Evakuieren selbstverständlich, ja, aber das Ausheizen nicht, also der.
Sich sozusagen nicht wirklich nennenswert Wasser daran angefunden hat bei diesem kleinen Do.
Ganz genau, weil es eben hochreiner Stickstoff war, ähm Stickstoff äh ist günstig, unsere Atmosphäre besteht ja überwiegend heraus und selbst als hoch eines Gas ist es dann auch äh sehr erschwinglich,
und da ist eben kein Wasser drin, deswegen kann sich auch kein Wasser auf den Wänden äh niederschlagen und äh die Belegung mit äh mit Stickstoff äh ist kein Problem. Das äh kriegt man leicht genug von den Wänden wieder runter.
Also das war das einzige Mal, äh dass das System nicht unter Vakuum war und ansonsten ist es jetzt seit äh.
Dreiundzwanzig Jahr.
Nicht schlecht, aber es wird die ganze Zeit nachgepumpt als.
Ja, ja, selbstverständlich, laufen die ganze Zeit pumpen. Äh, wir haben insgesamt äh fünf Turbomodulpumpen, an jedem Ende des Rohres eins und dann für die Modenkliena, von dem wir vorhin gesprochen hatten, haben wir auch noch eine Pumpe.
Und den Druck, den wir so erreichen, das hängt ein kleines bisschen
auch von der Temperatur, von der Außentemperatur, weil doch immer noch ein kleines bisschen Wasser äh auf den Wänden ist. Wir liegen so im äh einmal zehn minus acht Bereich
Im Winter ist das ein bisschen niedriger, also wir haben zehn Uhr minus neun Bereiche, zehn noch minus acht Milliliter.
Okay, aber jetzt müssen wir dann doch nochmal natürlich auf die Spiegel zu sprechen kommen. Das habe ich jetzt gerade äh etwas äh vorzeitig äh unterbrochen, weil äh,
das scheint ja schon so auch ein bisschen so ein Herzstück dieser ganzen Geschichte äh äh zu sein, was so das,
Fine-Engineering äh betrifft, weil letzten Endes sind wir ja immer noch äh immer noch auf dem Weg möglichst wenig Störungen zu haben,
So, wir haben möglichst wenig Störungen im ausgesendeten Licht
haben dann möglichst wenig Störungen auf dem Weg zu diesem Spiegel, in dem diese Rohre äh vakuumiert sind und einfach mög,
so wenig äh Moleküle von was auch immer. Äh da ist, an dem sich das Licht in irgendeiner Form noch weiter stören könnte, brechen könnte. Dann trifft es halt auf diese Spiegel,
und diese Spiegel sind tja, wenn man jetzt sagt, spiegelding natürlich jeder so ein bisschen an seinem Badezimmerspiegel, aber das ist ja nicht so ganz das, äh, worauf man jetzt.
Nee, das hat mit Badezimmerspiegeln nicht mehr wirklich viel zu tun. Ähm zum die Anforderungen an diese Spiegel sind zum einen, sie sollen das Licht möglichst verlustfrei reflektieren.
Und sie sollen das Licht ohne nennenswerte Verzerrungen wieder reflektieren. Da kommt jetzt also
ein wunderbar gereinigter Leserstrahl an. Den hatten wir durch unsere Modenkliener geschickt und der ist jetzt sehr schön sauber in in seiner Form. Und wenn wir den jetzt von einem Spiegel
der äh nicht sehr,
Plan oder auch nicht sehr kugelförmig ist, der Dellen hat und Abweichung hat, wenn wir den davon wieder zurückschicken würden,
und das in beiden Armen unterschiedlich, dann würden am Strahlteiler, wo wir die zurückkommenden Strahlen dann wieder überlagern, würden die nicht mehr zueinander passen.
Und dann wäre unser Interferenzbild, was wir bekommen,
nicht mehr, so wie wir das wollen. In unserem Fall wollen wir an dem Interverometer Ausgang einen sehr dunklen Ausgang haben. Das heißt,
wir sind darauf angewiesen, dass die beiden zurückkommenden Strahlen sich sehr schön destruktiv auslöschen,
und wenn die Wellenfronten nicht mehr zueinander passen, weil die Spiegeloberfläche nicht gut genug ist, dann geht das nicht.
Was nimmt man dann also als Spiegel.
Man nimmt als Spiegelmaterial, nimmt man Quarzglas, hoch eines Quarzglas, was äh besonders für die Transmittierten Optiken wichtig ist, also in Strahlteile im G sechshundert Fall.
Hoch deswegen, weil man dort möglichst wenig absorbieren möchte. Man möchte möglichst wenig von dem Licht verlieren,
die müssen auch von der Homogenität her muss das Glas äh sehr ausgezeichnet sein, da dürfen keine Einschlüsse, davon keine Bläschen drin sein, weil sonst wieder zu viel leserlich gestreut würde,
in verschiedenste Richtungen, wo es dann zum Beispiel von Vakuumsystem wenden, wieder reflektiert werden könnte und dann stör.
Das heißt, man braucht ein Material, was sehr wenig Licht absorbiert, was sehr homogen ist. Dann muss man dafür sorgen, dass die Spiegeloberfläche sehr, sehr präzise poliert wir.
Damit die reflektierte Wellenfront des Lasers die gewünschte Form hat, sage ich mal. Also zum einen, in beiden Armen exakt das Gleiche,
aber da wir das Laserlicht äh nochmal wieder verwenden, da wir recycling Techniken äh muss die Krümmung der Spiegel äh,
exakt passen. Der Laserstrahl muss genau in sich zurückreflektiert werden.
Wenn man jetzt also so ein super polierter Quarzglas Oberfläche hat, dann reflektiert die natürlich noch nicht sehr viel.
Typisches Glas, jede Glasoberfläche reflektiert etwa, vier Prozent, äh, unter senkrechtem Einfall.
Das nutzt uns natürlich nichts, wir brauchen hochreflektierende Spiegel,
unsere Endspiegel zum Beispiel haben eine transmission von etwa acht PPM acht äh acht Paar Million.
Und dazu werden die Quarzglas Oberflächen beschichtet mit die elektrischen Schichten,
das ist immer abwechselnd, Silitium, Dioxid, Tantal Pentoxid, wieder Silizon, Tantal Pentoxid, die haben leicht unterschiedliche Brechungsindizes und wenn man das dann richtig macht,
dann kann man dadurch, dass die Teilreflektion, an all diesen Übergängen sich äh korrekt addieren, kann man extrem hohe Reflektivitäten sehr nah von eins eben mit Transmissionen, von wenigen PPM erreichen.
Worauf bezieht sich denn jetzt das PPM auf das, was man verliert oder.
Das, was man verliert, was man transmettiert, zum Beispiel oder auch absorbiert.
Okay, also acht Teile von einer Millionen Teile.
Acht Teile von einer Million werden, in dem Fall transmittiert äh und auch diese Beschichtungs äh Materialien und die Beschichtungsvorgänge,
müssen so gut und sauber sein, dass man auch in den Schichten wenig verliert da ist. Die Richtschnur heutzutage,
einige zehntel pro Million. Also ähm ungefähr äh null Komma ein PPM.
Okay, also da gehen so neunundneunzig Komma neun neun neun neun neun Prozent äh äh Licht, werden gehen wieder zurück und so will man das irgendwie auch haben.
Ganz genauso will man das haben.
So und jetzt nochmal zu dieser Aufhängung, weil das fand ja schon so,
extra pfiffiges Ding zu sein. Also, der Spiegel muss natürlich gut reflektieren, das Hut er jetzt, jetzt haben wir irgendwie den Superspiegel, quas Glas, alles äh total schick
äh poliert und vor allem auch korrekt beschichtet. Es geht wirklich nur minimal irgendwas äh verloren, aber der Spiegel ist natürlich nichts wert, wenn er nicht in die richtige
Richtung zeigt. Und,
bedeutet natürlich, da muss er erstmal überhaupt erstmal in die richtige Richtung äh zeigen, aber da muss er dann eben diese Position auch halten. Und das Ding hängt jetzt an Glasfasern.
Ja, da sind noch wieder einen anderen Grund. Also ähm jetzt erstmal haben wir ja schon darüber geredet, dass dass Jojo, dass das Pendel dafür sorgt, dass er von der Seismick isoliert ist.
Und jetzt wollen wir.
Aber das funktioniert doch nur, also aber es gibt nur diese Aufhängung. Also, das Ding, der, der Spiegel hängt an Glasfasern, das ist das Jojo, von dem wir jetzt sprechen oder gibt's noch eine andere Aufhängung.
Äh nee, das ist, das ist schon die Aufhängung, aber erstmal ist es so,
dass äh dieser eine Pendelstufe, also die ist eine Jojo, äh das macht bei äh einer bestimmten Frequenz, sagen wir mal bei hundert Hertz, eben eine gewisse Unterdrückung der Seisma.
Wenn die Pendelfrequenz äh ein Herz ist, das heißt, wenn das äh Jojo etwa äh was gehört und dazu etwa dreißig Zentimeter, die wenn die Schnur etwa dreißig Zentimeter lang ist, dann,
würde das eine Pendelfrequenz von ungefähr einem Herz ergeben,
Und das würde bedeuten, dass es bei hundert Hertz dann eine Unterdrückung, das sei es ein bisschen Bewegung, um hundert Quadrat, das fällt mit eins durch Frequenz Quadratfelders a.
Unterdrückung von hundert äh von zehntausend bei hundert Hertz, reicht uns aber bei weitem nicht aus. Wir müssen die,
Erdbewegung, die ständig äh existierende Erdbewegung, wir reden jetzt nicht von Erdbeben, sondern von der Mikrosais, mit, die zum Beispiel durch die Nordseewellen verursacht wird, wir reden von dem Laster, der auf der Straße fährt.
Tür.
Von allem von von uns, die wir rumlaufen,
das muss äh ja das Wetter auch ähm Wetter ist äh in der Regel, also hauptsächlich ist da Wind, weil ansonsten die Änderungen zu Niederfrequenzen.
Das muss man ungefähr zwölf Größenordnung,
runtergedrückt werden. Das das geht mit einer Pendelstufe nicht und deswegen hängen wir den Aufhängepunkt einfach nochmal auf. Dann ist der auch wieder um diese Faktor isoliert,
und den hängen wir nochmal auf. Also bei GO sechshundert verwenden wir drei Fachpendel. Drei Stufen von Pendeln hintereinander.
Und es heißt jetzt einfach nur so ein, so eine passive Konstruktion oder wird dann auch irgendwie aktiv äh gegengeführt, weil wenn dieses, dieses Bild, was ich jetzt im Kopf habe, mit, äh, man muss das Pendel im Prinzip oben die ganze Zeit gezielt hin und her zittern,
um unten die Bewegung aufzufangen. Das war doch, wie es gemeint war, oder?
Nein, das ist äh das ist nicht was gemeint ist. Wenn der Aufhängepunkt, also wenn, wenn keine weiteren Störungen vorhanden sind. Und ich äh wackelte den Aufhängepunkt, nehme mal mir mal wieder einen Einfachpendel, also wie dann das einfacher, yo, yo.
Ich zittere den Aufhängepunkt mit einhundert Herz hin und her.
Dann bewegt sich die aufgehängte Masse, das Jojo in diesem Fall, nur mit einer sehr geringen Amplitude.
Soweit ist alles gut, bei hohen Frequenzen ist alles bestens, aber nun haben wir natürlich noch die Resonanzfrequenz außer Acht gelassen. Auf der Resonanzfrequenz.
Würde das natürlich entsprechend überhöht schwingen. Und da müssen wir was gegen tun.
Das Aufschaukeln.
Das Aufschaukeln müssen wir verhindern, denn ansonsten würden die aufgehängten Spiegel sich bei ihrer Resonanzfrequenz oder beider äh bei den Resonanzfrequenzen dieses jetzt etwas komplizierter,
gestalteten Gebildes würden die zu sehr schwingen. Und da müssen wir was gegen tun,
Und das machen wir, indem wir an der obersten Masse, da wir, äh, messen die Bewegung der obersten Masse, relativ zur Erde.
Und dämpfen das Ganze,
Das heißt, wir haben um die oberste Masse herum von diesen äh drei aufgehängten Massen, haben wir, wenn in das Schattensensoren, also optische Sensoren, die messen, wie viel sich diese Masse bewegt, relativ zum Aufhängesystem.
Das wird dann durch ein Regelsystem, durch eine elektronisches Regelsystem geschickt, auf Aktuatoren.
Das muss man sich so ein bisschen ähnlich wie ein Lautsprecher vorstellen. Wir haben kleine Magneter, auch diese oberste Masse gekle.
Und außen drum rum sind äh Magnetspulen, durch die wir variierenden Strom durchschicken können.
Und wenn jetzt also das gemessene Signal entsprechend elektronisch aufbereitet wird und auf den Aktuator geschickt, kann man damit die Pendelbewegungen dämpfen.
Also beider Frequenz der Pendelbewegung, was tun, aber bei den höheren Frequenzen, wo das Pendel ja von sich aus schon wunderbar passiv isoliert, filtern wir das entsprechend so, dass da nichts passiert.
Mhm. Also mit diesen äh Spulen wird also das Magnetfeld sehr feinkörnig ähm gesteuert, um sozusagen diese restlichen Bewegungen auch noch rauszufü.
Um auf den Resonanzfrequenzen die Bewegung zu verhindern, ganz genau.
Und wie viel Ruhe kriegt man dann letzten Endes hin? Also kriegt man damit alles weg.
Damit kriegt man nicht alles weg. Äh man könnte indem man das vielstufig baut, könnte man die Kopplung, der Seiß mit,
auf den Spiegel immer weiter reduzieren,
aber äh das, das ist nicht das letzte Wort, was da äh zu sprechen ist, denn da kommt einem wieder die Temperatur,
in der in dem System steckende,
Energie bei einer endlichen Temperatur bei Zimmertemperatur kommt einem da äh wieder ins Gehege.
Weil Temperatur ist Bewegung.
Temperatur ist Bewegung ähm und das, das kann man besser verstehen, wenn man sich einen umgekehrten Prozess anguckt, wenn ich einen Pendel habe und ich rege das an, eine Schaukel zum Beispiel,
oder wieder unser Jojo. Und ich rege das an.
Und lasse das Pendeln, dann wird die Amplitude immer geringer und geringer werden. Und ein Teil des Verlustmechanismuses steckt in der Aufhängung.
Das äh sei der Draht, die Faser, mit der ich das aufhänge, biegt sich beim Schwingen natürlich ein bisschen.
In der Biegung geht Energie verloren.
Das heißt, ich habe da einen Mechanismus, der makroskopische Bewegung umwandelt in thermischer Energie, in Wärme.
Und das ist keine Einbahnstraße, es geht nicht nur in die eine Richtung, das geht auch in die andere Richtung. Ich habe also einen Kopplungsmechanismus der Wärme an Bewegung, an Makroskopische Bewegung koppel.
Das hat zur Folge, wenn ich einen solchen Verlustmechanismus habe, also Stichwort ist da äh Fluktuationsdisziplinstheore,
Äh wenn ich einen solchen Mechanismus habe, dann sorgt mir das dafür, dass die Temperatur mir Makroskopische Bewegung erzeugt. Das heißt, ich muss diese Koppelung möglichst klein machen,
Ich könnte natürlich das Ganze runterkühlen, sodass der thermische Impuls, das die thermische Energie niedrig ist. Das ist sehr, sehr aufwendig,
ich kann aber auch dafür sorgen, dass die Kopplung sehr niedrig ist. Und das machen wir durch die Glasfaser. Die oberen Stufen hängen wir alle an Edelstahldrähten auf,
an Klaviert Seiten sozusagen. Die haben schon eine relativ hohe Güte, aber bei weitem nicht gut genug.
Und die unterste Stufe wird dann an Quarzglasfasern aufgehäng.
Weil die sich thermisch anders verhalten.
Weil die mechanische Güte von äh denen sehr viel höher ist und das Ganze wird auch ähm wir nennen das quasi monolithisch,
ausgeführt, das heißt, an den oberen Stufen haben wir die Massen in äh Stahldraht, Schlaufen, aber jede Schlaufe löst sich natürlich irgendwo mal,
und an diesen Ablösepunkten kann es ein bisschen Reibung geben und diese Reibung führt dann wieder zu Verlusten und andersrum wieder zu einer Koppelung von dem Wärmebad, an die mechanische markroskopische Bewegung und das verhindern wir dadurch,
dass wir die Quarzglasfasern, das sind dünne Quarzglasfasern äh etwa dreihundert Mikrometer Durchmesser,
die schweißen wir an kleine Blöcke, Quarzglasböcke, wir nennen das Ohren, weil wenn man, wenn man von vorne guckt, dann sieht das so ein bisschen aus, wie wir mit den Kopfhörern auf,
Das heißt, da sind kleine Quarzglas,
Klötze an den Spiegeln dran und äh da schweißen wir die Fasern an und dann gibt es keinen Punkt mehr, wo es sich reiben kann, dann ist nur noch die Biegung da, das minimiert den mechanischen Verluste,
und minimiert damit auch das eingefügte Rauschen. Wir nennen das thermisches Rauschen,
Das thermische Rauschen ist äh ist ein großer, feinter Gravitationsfällen, Forscher. Das das taucht,
vielen Stellen auf und äh wir müssen da die verschiedensten Wege suchen, um das um das zu.
Ist dieses Prinzip von vornherein schon so gewählt worden, also waren sich von Anfang an schon sicher, so wollen wir das jetzt bauen oder ist das jetzt auch so ein Interationsprozess der äh sukzessive sich äh verbessert hat in den letzten dreiundzwanzig Jahren.
Also diese monolithische Aufhängung äh es es war zur Anfangszeit von GO sechshundert schon bekannt, dass äh dieser Punkt ähm ein eine Begrenzung,
angelimitation darstellen wird. Das heißt, wir haben das in Geo von Anfang an so gemacht.
Die Technik war aber bei weitem noch nicht ausgereift genug. Das das ist auch etwas, was speziell unsere Glasgower-Kollegen sehr vorangetrieben haben,
und die Tatsache, dass sich das bei Geos gut bewährt hat, hat dann auch dazu geführt, dass es in der zweiten Generation der größeren Detektoren jetzt auch eingebaut wurde,
Also es gab's bei einigen äh dieser Technologien, dass Geo sechshundert.
Im Gegensatz zu äh Prototypen der kleineren Klasse,
hinreichend äh nah an den großen Gravitationswellen Detektoren dran war, dass dann die Überzeugungsarbeit geleistet werden konnte. Ja, das hat sich da bewährt,
geht so, das machen wir so.
Okay, also das, was ihr mit viel Aufwand in Groß äh schon hinbekommt, kriegen wir hier auch einen kleinen hin, wenn man das Kleine wiederum aufs Groß überträgt, dann würde sich entsprechend die Präzision oder die Störungsarmut dann entsprechend verbessern.
Okay, also wir haben jetzt den Laser. Wir haben die äh Mode äh Bereinigung und äh die Verteilung des Lichts äh was durch die,
vakuumierten Rühren durchgeht und dort auf die Spiegel trifft, die sehr viel Licht zurückschicken und die halt wunderbar von der Seismick, also von der ganzen Umgebung her,
koppelt sind, das ist dann also egal, wenn der Fuchs äh sich da trollt, äh weil von dieser Bewegung dann einfach nichts mehr auf den Spiegel land.
Heißt aber dann auch im Umkehrschluss, dass auch alle anderen Elemente, also nicht nur die an dem Ende, sondern äh auch natürlich in der Mitte,
auch alles entsprechend genauso aufgehängt sein muss und alles von dieser Seismick entkoppelt sein mu.
Es muss alles aufgehängt sein. Also der äh der Laser ist äh nicht aufgehängt, aber die Modenkliener, also Geogo sechshundert, H2, Bodenkinder in in Reihe geschaltet, um den äh nötigen Effekt zu erreichen,
ähm ab da ist alles aufgehäng.
Verschieden ausgefuchsten Aufhängungssystemen. Die Modenkliener zum Beispiel haben nur zwei Stufen, das reicht da aus,
und im Zentralinterview ist dann alles mit dreifach Pendelaufhängungen aufgehängt.
Jetzt gibt's glaube ich noch eine Besonderheit. Äh wir haben ja bisher immer äh so getan, als würde das in der Mitte aufgeteilt werden, dann fliegt's bis zum Ende und dann geht's wieder zurück. Es gibt aber hier noch so ein extra äh Kniff, also hier gibt's ja nochmal so eine.
Ja, es gibt da noch ein paar optische Kniffe.
Bei GEO sechshundert haben wir einen optischen Trick angewandt, der sich äh im Nachhinein als gar nicht so pfiffig herausgestellt hat. Wir haben den Arm einmal gefaltet.
Und die Idee dahinter war,
je länger die Armlänge, desto größer natürlich das Gravitationswellensignal, weil die Gravitation sehr lernen relative Dehnung macht und wenn der Arm doppelt so lang ist, dann ist die Verschiebung der ankommenden, der zurückkommenden Wellenfront natürlich doppelt so groß,
also haben wir den Arm einmal gefaltet.
Das heißt, es geht also zum Ende von dort nochmal zurück, aber nicht bis in die Mitte, sondern.
Bis fast in die Mitte, da hängt dann wieder einen Spiegel und schickt das dann den gleichen Pfad wieder zurück,
das heißt, äh, das Licht liegt jetzt auf seinem Gesamtweg von Strahlteiler, zu Endspiegel, zu Inboardspiegel, wie wir das nennen, weil da hinten wieder nah dran ist. Wieder zum fernen Spiegel und Strahltaler, zwei Komma vier Kilometer zurü.
Anstatt eins Komma zwei, wie es eigentlich wäre.
Genau, Stelle eins Komma zwei, äh sechshundert hin, sechshundert zurück. Ähm,
das hielten wir für eine gute Idee. Ähm, es stellte sich aber heraus, dass uns das thermische Rauschen wieder das thermische Rauschen diesmal der äh Spiegelbeschichtungen.
Äh da einen Strich durch die Rechnung macht, ähm weil sich das letztendlich, also das das stellt sich als äh einer der dominierenden Rauschfaktoren heraus und,
wenn man das korrekt aufaddiert, die ganzen Einzelbeiträge.
Dann äh führt das zu keiner nennenswerten Verbesserung diese Faltung. Also das würden wir heute nicht wieder so machen.
Das heißt, die Tatsache, dass man einfach noch einen weiteren Spiegel oder genau genommen ja sogar noch zwei mal äh auf den Spiegel auftritt,
Also am Ende dann wieder zurück, dann wieder ans Ende und wieder zurück. Das wäre ja sonst, wenn man äh entsprechend doppelt lange Schenkel länger hätte, hätte man halt nur einen Spiegelkont
sind es drei. Und jedes Mal,
nimmt quasi das Lichtsignal rauschen von der Beschichtung des Spiegels auf, ja.
Genau, genau. Und obwohl die, obwohl die Beschichtung nur wenige Mykometer dick ist, etwa fünf Mikrometer dick, ähm, macht die den Löwenanteil an dem thermischen Rausch.
Krass. Das heißt, werden die dann gekühlt, hätte man vielleicht bessere Ergebnisse, aber das wäre dann wiederum ein ganz anderer Aufwand an der Stelle.
Das ist ein ganz anderer Aufwand, äh das ist allerdings ein Weg, der in der Zukunft gegangen werden wird, äh der bei einem der jetzigen Detektoren, nämlich dem japanischen Kargradetektor, auch jetzt schon gegangen wird.
Der Weg wird gegangen, man ist noch nicht angekommen.
Weil's noch nicht fertig gebaut.
Es läuft, aber im Augenblick bei der Zimmertemperatur. Aber es ist vorgesehen gekühlt zu werden,
Ja, aber also das ist jetzt der eine optische Trick. Äh wir haben also ähm versucht, die Armlänge ähm zu verlängern,
das das wirft natürlich auch sofort die Frage auf, wenn ihr das für eine gute Idee hielt, das einmal zu falten, warum habt ihr das nicht hundert Mal gefaltet,
das ist ein Konzept, was auch schon am dreißig Meter Prototypen in Garching verfolgt wurde. Das hat aber technische Nachteile,
einmal, wenn man einmal faltet, dann kann man es erreichen,
dass man für einen der Spiegel keine Kontrollsignale braucht, ähm indem die Krümmung der Spiegels äh korrekt gewählt wird. Denn über was wir bisher noch nicht geredet haben, ist ja die Spiegel müssen jetzt natürlich auch noch korrekt ausgerichtet sein,
und auch an exakt der richtigen Position. Längst des Laserstrahls. Denn was wir haben wollen, ist, dass wir,
am Interverometer Ausgang,
ähm wollen wir's möglichst dunkel haben. Ähm und das erreichen wir nur, wenn die zurückkommenden Wellen aus den beiden Armen, sich an dem Ausgang nahezu destruktiv auslöschen.
Dazu müssen wir die Spiegel aber auf einer bestimmten Position halten. Äh bei ganz, ganz niedrigen Frequenzen müssen wir das an einer bestimmten Position halten.
Also salopp gesagt, muss ja der eine Schenkel sozusagen eine halbe Welle weiter hinten stehen.
Salopp gesagt, ja, äh, aber aufgrund der Phasenbeziehung am Strahlteiler ist es, äh, würde es für exakt gleichlang passen.
Exakt gleich lang sind die Arme aber nicht, die sind bewusst unterschiedlich lang,
nämlich siebeneinhalb Zentimeter etwa unterschiedlich lang, aber das hat wieder technische Gründe. Das hat äh Gründe,
äh die darin liegen, dass man eben Fehler, Signale sich erzeugen muss, um die Spiegelposition genau an der richtigen Stelle halten zu können,
und auch die Spiegelorientierung. Die Strahlen müssen natürlich in die richtige Richtung wieder zurückgehen.
Ähm die Strahlen müssen aufm Strahlteiler, beide exakt überlagert werden.
Die sollen sich ebenso gut es geht zum zum Ausgang hin auslöschen.
Und dazu muss ich mir Fehlersignale erzeugen, das mache ich über eine Modulationsmethode, also ich moduliere die Phase des reingehenden Lichtes und ich kriege nur dann Signale am Ausgang, wenn die Arme ein bisschen unterschiedlich lang sind.
Das nennt man Schnuppmodulation, das hat sich die Lise schnupp in Garching seiner Zeit, mal überlegt und deswegen heißt das so, das wird äh überall auch verwendet, diese Methode für die Erzeugung von Fehlersingen an.
Okay, also wenn jetzt alles richtig eingestellt ist, dann ähm.
Löscht sich der Laserstrahl aus, an der Stelle, wo man Mist. Das heißt, man misst eigentlich, wenn im Idealfall sozusagen, wenn nichts passiert, ist alles dunkel.
Jein, fast. Äh da müssen wir tatsächlich nochmal ein bisschen näher drauf eingehen, denn das scheint erscheint ja ein bisschen paradox, dass wir den Ausgang, an dem wir messen, jetzt dunkel machen wollen. Ähm,
wenn wir ähm wenn wir uns mal vorstellen, es wäre exakt dunkel. Und das käme eine Gravitationswelle,
dann wird das natürlich ein kleines bisschen heller. Das heißt, wir könnten im Prinzip die Existenz einer Gravitationswelle detektieren. Wir wussten aber gar nicht, in welche Richtung geht das denn jetzt? Setzt der Nordarm länger geworden, ist der Ostarmlänger geworden. Das heißt, wir haben keine Vorzeicheninformation.
Das kann man damit umgehen, dass wir das äh Laserlicht modulieren, dass ein ähnlichen Effekt hat, als wenn wir die Armlänge mit Radiofrequenzen, ein kleines bisschen modulieren würden.
Also was modelliert wird die Amplitude moduliert oder die Frequ.
Nee, es wird die Phase modelliert.
Ja, die Phase des reinkommenden Laserlichts und das hat den gleichen Effekt ähm mit diesen leicht unterschiedlichen Armlängen, hat das den gleichen Effekt, als wenn man die Armlänge ein bisschen modellieren würde. Und dann kann man ein Vorzeichen.
Auch wenn man exakt auf dunkel sitzen würde und es kommt jetzt eine Gravitationswelle und weicht in die eine Richtung ein bisschen ab. Äh dann könnte man auch die Vorzeicheninformation rauskriegen.
Das hat man auch eine Zeit lang so gemacht. Wir haben auch Geo eine Zeit lang äh so betrieben. Ähm das hat aber auch wieder,
rausch-, technischen Nachteil, man erzeugt sich damit ein klein bisschen zusätzliches Rauschen, was man vermeiden kann.
Wenn wir stattdessen jetzt nicht ganz bei völliger Auslöschung, also nicht ganz im Minimum sitzen, sondern ein kleines bisschen daneben.
Das heißt, wir weichen jetzt ein kleines bisschen von gleichen Armlängen ab. Und jetzt macht die Gravitationswelle den einen Arm, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen länger, dann würde es heller werden oder sie macht den selben Arm kürzer, dann wird es ein bisschen dunkler werden, da habe ich meine Vorzeicheninformation.
Nun denkt man zunächst, dass, äh, wenn man nah am Minimum sitzt, wo ja die Steigung der Kurve flach ist, dass man da auch entsprechend wenig empfindlich ist,
weil das Signal natürlich flach ist. Also wenn die Gravitationswelle meine relative Armlänge ändert, dann ändert sich die aufgrund der Flachheit dieser Kurve im Minimum,
dann ändert sich die Intensität auf meiner Fotodiode wenig.
Das heißt, man würde sagen, dann geht auch ein bisschen zu äh größeren Abweichungen, wo die Kurve steiler wird. Dann kriege ich auch mehr Signal, aber dann kriege ich auch mehr Rauschen,
Und das ist eine weitere äh Klasse von Rauschen, die wir noch gar nicht angesprochen haben. Äh das Licht selbst rauscht auch.
Das heißt, wenn ich einen Laserstrahl nehme und diesen Laserstrahl so gut stabilisiere, wie es nur irgend geht,
dann rauscht das trotzdem noch.
Einfach, weil die Welt so ist.
Einfach, weil die Welt so ist. In dem Fall ist die Welt krantisiert, äh die Lichtfelder sind quantisiert. Es gibt Fotonen,
und die Tatsache, dass das Licht fällt, Quantisiert ist, erzeugt ein minimales Rauschen.
Also quantisiert, das ist sozusagen, dass das Bild von, von Welle und äh äh Teilchen. Wir reden die ganze Zeit über äh Wellen und stellen uns immer so schöne Linien vor, wie man sie auf,
das Papier malt, aber wenn man sich's halt genau anschaut, dann hat man's dann doch auch äh, je nachdem, wie man drauf blickt, auch mit Ereignissen zu tun, die sozusagen in der Summe diese Welle äh ausmachen.
Und an der Stelle, ja,
ist man wirklich so in der Quanten äh mechanischen Realität und dort entsteht das Rauschen, weil da nicht alles so gleichmäßig verteilt ist, wie man das so eigentlich annimmt.
Ja, sowieso könnte man es auch sagen, ähm letztendlich äh liegt es da dran, dass das äh Elektromonetische Feld eine Mindestenergie hat.
Also das äh das wird dann ein bisschen schwer vorstellbar, selbst wenn ich absolute Dunkelheit habe. Also den niedrigstmöglichen Energiezustand, keine Fotonen sind vorhanden.
Null Kelvin.
Dann nehme mit der Temperatur jetzt nicht, also einfach Dunkelheit, elektromagnetisch, äh kein, keine elektromagnetischen Fehler. Ähm.
Dann habe ich trotzdem noch Fluktuationen des Elektromagnetischen Feldes. Wir nennen das Vakuumfluktuation.
Und diese Vakuumfluktuation sind Obnipräsent. Überall sind die. Ähm und äh die, die äh spucken einem da in die Suppe. Die machen einem das Messen schwer.
Anderes Stichwort unter dem, dass auch läuft, ist Rotrauschen, das schrotrauschendes Licht ist.
Schrot, weil man äh sich das so wie auf ein, sagen wir mal, Blech prasselnden äh Schrot, Salve vorstellt. Also.
Also Gewehr, Schrotgewehr, Schuss.
Ungleichmäßige Verteilung von von Partikel.
Ungleichmäßige äh speziell in der zeitlichen Abfolge, Verteilung und Ankunftszeit von von Partikeln, in dem Fall Futonen.
Das das erzeugt eben das Schrotrauschen und dieses Schrotrauschen äh steigt mit der Wurzel der Leistung.
Ähm so dass äh letztendlich ganz egal wie weit ich da unten vom Minimum entfernt bin,
mein Signal zu Rausch, also das Signal steigt natürlich, weil die äh Steigung dieser Kurve, je weiter ich da von Minimum entfernt bin, wird sie größer. Mein Rauschen steigt aber leider auch,
und zwar im gleichen Maße.
So, dass es dann eigentlich egal ist.
Eigentlich in der Nähe des Minimums ist es egal.
Nun stellt sich natürlich noch die Frage, warum wollen wir denn überhaupt das Minimum sein? Äh wir könnten ja auch zum Beispiel auf der Hälfte messen.
Aber wenn wir ihn zum Interverometer mit äh wie das jetzt bei GEO sechshundert, der Fall ist, mit sagen wir mal einigen Watt äh Lichtleistungen reingehen.
Müssten wir dann entsprechend auch einige Watt oder Hälfte von ihnen einigen. Am Ausgang detektieren, das ist technisch schwierig.
Man kann äh niedrigere Leistungen äh einige Milliarden kann man sehr, sehr viel leichter, detektieren, Schrotrausch begrenzt detektieren. Zum anderen ist es so.
Wir haben, er hat ja gesagt, wir haben da den Strahltaler, teilt das äh auf und dann haben wir da hinten irgendwie die Spiegel, die sind so toll beschichtet, da geht auch kein Licht verloren, das kommt jetzt alles zurück,
und jetzt stellen wir die relativen Phasen so ein, dass es sich zu unserem Ausgang praktisch weginterferiert. Da muss das ja irgendwo bleiben.
Und das geht zum zweiten Ausgang des Strahlteilers. Sprich, zurück in Richtung Gläser.
Das ist äh im Prinzip äh unerwünscht, ich hab mir jetzt viel Mühe gegeben, das ganze Leserlicht da zu erzeugen, das ist natürlich auf der einen Seite eine Verschwendung und auf der anderen Seite mag der Leser das auch nicht so gerne.
Dieses Licht kann man aber noch wieder verwenden. Man kann da einen Spiegel reinstellen. Den sogenannten Power Recyclingspiegel. Und der Name sagt auch schon, was da passiert.
Ich nehme jetzt dieses Licht, was in Richtung Gläser zurückgehen will und schicke das einfach wieder ins Intervermeter rein.
Das Interverometer selbst Strahlteile plus Spiegel wirkt jetzt wie ein Spiegel in Richtung Gläser. Und was ich mir jetzt aufgebaut habe, ist ein optischer Resonator aus dem Power Recyclingspiegel und dem Interverometer.
Und da drin, so ähnlich wie wir das vorhin bei den Modengliedern gesagt haben, kann sich die Lichtleistung wieder aufschaukeln.
Das heißt, obwohl ich jetzt nur, äh, sagen wir mal, fünf Watt ins Interverometer reinschicke, habe ich im Interverometer eine viel höhere Lichtleistung.
Bei GO sechshundert machen wir das so, der Power Recyclingspiegel hat eine Transmission von äh einem Tausendstel, einem Promi,
so dass wir mit diesem Trick die Leistung im Interverometer um den Faktor tausend überhöhen.
Obwohl wir also nur fünf Watt reinschicken, haben wir im Interverwometer fünf Kilowatt umlaufen.
Und das geht natürlich nur, wenn ich am Ausgang wenig Licht verliere,
Das heißt, da haben wir mal Glück gehabt, eine Win-win-Situation. Wir können es leicht detektieren,
die Empfindlichkeit äh wird nicht schlechter, wegen der Schrotrauschen, zwei, weil das, äh, zumindest in der Nähe des Minimums,
unabhängig ist. Und ich kann die Laserleistung ähm Resonant überhöhen und habe damit natürlich ein entsprechend größeres Signal.
Es muss aber so präzise sein, dass dann eben auch das wieder eingespeiste äh äh also exakt mit dem eingespeisten Licht über.
Das muss exakt in Phase sein, die Länge dieser Power Recycling Capity, das heißt, die Position, dieses Spiegels muss natürlich exakt kontrolliert werden. Also, die die Spiegelpositionen.
Ähm bei bei sehr niedrigen Frequenzen werden auf äh auf besser als im Pikometern genau kontrolliert.
Ein Pikometer ist so im Vergleich zu so einem Atom, wie viel.
Also ein ein Atomdurchmesser liegt äh in der Größenordnung von äh einem Angströmen. Das ist ein zehntel Nanometer, das da das heißt, es wären hundert Pigometer. Also schon deutlich, sub-Atoma.
Okay, das ist die Genauigkeit, mit der diese Spiegel auf die richtige Stelle geschoben werden.
Genau. Und die Änderungen, die.
Durch diese elektromannetischen Felder, die durch diese Spulen auch wieder.
Ja, das kann man auch mit äh den Spulen machen. Äh wir haben für diese Feinjustage und auch andere Aktuatoren, sogenannte Elektrostatische Aktuatoren. Da werden elektrische Felder verwendet, um das zu machen.
Das heißt, hinter dem Spiegel ist, wird sozusagen nochmal so ein Feld äh aufgebaut, was einfach den den Spiegel einfach nur durch seine Wirkung auf das Material drückt.
Ja, wir haben äh hinter den, in, in unserem Fall hinter den Inboardspiegeln, also hinter dem äh, die wieder nahe dran sind, haben wir nochmal einen Dreifachpendel aufgehängt, nahezu identisches Dreifachpendel,
und auf die unterste Quarz, auf den, also ein Spiegel ist es nicht nur, weil er nicht beschichtet ist, aber ist auch eine Quarzglas, äh, Zylinder, da haben wir,
äh Elektroden, Goldelektroden aufgedampft, wo wir dann eine Spannung anlegen, etwa sechshundert Volt,
das macht ein inhomogenes elektrisches Feld und das zieht dann den Spiegel rein. Und durch die Variation dieser Spannung hat man dann eben Akkuator hat man eine Möglichkeit den Spiegel.
Pikometer genau ein.
Auf und pikometer genau einzustellen, ganz genau.
Krass.
Und das ist immer noch immer noch riesig gegen das, was letztendlich gemessen wird.
Also dieser, diese Piko-Meter ähm off-Set vom von der kompletten Auslöschung,
ähm die ähm erzeugen eben eine Leistung auf der letztendlich auf der Fotodiode, ähm auf auf den Ausgang können wir auch gleich nochmal ein bisschen eingehen,
äh auf dieser Fotodiode erzeugen, die eine Leistung von einigen Milliwat.
Und diese Leistung wird wiederum mit äh etwa zehn Hochminus.
Sagen wir mal in zehn Uhr minus neuner Bereich relativ ausgemessen. Also mit Ceno Minus, also mit im Pikowattbereich.
Bereich. Mhm. Nee, Ärztebereich. Ja. Okay. Also, ich fasse nochmal zusammen,
den ganzen Weg. Wir haben den Laser, der Laser äh schickt schon mal ganz korrektes äh Licht los, aber man will das halt äh richtig geradeaus haben, deswegen geht es durch diesen optischen ähm,
äh Filter
Moden Cleaner, der äh das liegt einerseits so ein bisschen auf äh Schaukel, aber dabei vor allem also alles, was nicht in die richtige Richtung geht, fliegt raus, über ein paar weitere Spiegel geht's dann das eigentliche System. Es gibt den Strahlenteiler, der schickt die,
äh den Lichtstrahl auf Hälfte Hälfte in ungefähr neunzig Grad Winkel äh raus.
Optischen Knick. Den wollen wir ja eigentlich gar nicht äh haben lassen jetzt mal raus. Das fliegt also wieder äh zurück. Das ganze System ist so eingestellt, dass wir eben das eigentliche messsignal sehr schwach,
empfangen, was technische Vorteile hat, aber auch vor allem kein Nachteil ist, weil wir sonst eben auf der anderen Seite in dieses Quantenproblem reinrennen würden, wo es dann eher wieder anfängt, zu rauschen und Rauschen ist halt generell immer der Feind. Ne, also Rauschen ist ja einfach der Fein.
Rauschen ist der Feind. Ganz deutlich.
So, äh, das restliche Licht, was ja auch noch irgendwo hin muss, weil die Energie geht ja nicht äh so ohne Weiteres äh verloren
die äh wird einfach ins System wieder eingespeist und äh erhöht damit automatisch die Gesamtenergieleistung des Systems, was er seine,
seine äh Messgenauigkeit auch äh weiterhin hochhält. Und jetzt sind wir sozusagen endlich
an dem Punkt angelangt, wo wir dann wirklich mal das Signal betrachten können, worum's uns ja jetzt
eigentlich geht. Und das Ganze schlägt dann bei dieser äh Diode auf.
Noch nicht ganz,
noch nicht ganz. Denn äh jetzt kommt das Licht also zum Ausgang raus. Und da machen wir nochmal einen ähnlichen Trick wie mit dem Power-Recycling. Da haben wir die Laser-Leistung äh zurückgeschickt und überhöht,
Am Ausgang kommen jetzt ja aber die Signale aus.
Die aber relativ schwach sind.
Die sind relativ schwach. Die schicken wir jetzt aber auch nochmal zurück und überhöhen die auch nochmal Resonant.
Das ist wieder so ein bisschen so ein Schaukleffekt. Wenn ich mich nur für die Resonanzfrequenz interessiere,
dann äh könnte ich zum Beispiel äh eine relativ geringe Bewegung am Aufhängepunkt einer Schaukel,
viel besser detektieren, dadurch, dass sich die Bildung der Schaukel selbst messe, weil das eben Resonant überhöht wird. Die die Bewegung da ist viel größer.
Aber will ja alles betrachten.
Ja, das ist jetzt aber eine Frage der äh der Resonanzbandbreite. Und äh da ist es so, ich stelle jetzt also in den Ausgang einen Spiegel rein, ich baue mir also einen optischen Resonator.
Der überhöht mir das Signal der Gravitationswellen in diesem Resonatoresonant. Und das macht da in einer gewissen Bandbreite,
Die Bandbreite hängt letztendlich von der äh reflektivität diese Spiegels ab. Das heißt, mit der Reflektivität, diese Spiegels kann ich die Bandbreite innerhalb der die Signale überhöht werden, einstellen,
Also es ist, äh, klingt ein bisschen kontraintuitiv. Ich stelle da einen Spiegel rein und der, die Signale, die hinter dem Spiegel rauskommen werden, größer, aber das klappt eben wegen dieser Resonanzüberhöhung.
Das ist ein äh ein ein Trick, der auch in den äh zu den späten Zeiten des äh Garching-Prototypen dort äh entwickelt wurde,
das haben wir da zum ersten Mal ausprobiert, haben das hier bei GO sechshundert,
dann äh eingebaut und äh getestet, erfolgreich getestet,
und diese erfolgreichen Tests haben dann auch die äh anderen überzeugt, äh ne und das ist jetzt auch in den.
Beiden Leigo-Detektoren eingebaut und Single Recycling wird auch jetzt in etwas eingebaut werden.
Das heißt, wird jetzt noch ein paar besser da.
Es wird bald, dadurch nochmal verbessert. Einen weiteren optischen Trick, den wir bei Geo nicht eingebaut haben, der aber in den anderen Detektoren eingebaut ist, ist nochmal wieder ein Objektcharesenator,
und zwar diesmal in jedem Arm einer,
Äh der Trick ist wieder ganz genau der gleiche. Ich schicke Licht in den optischen Resonator und auf der Resonanz wird die Leistung im optischen Resonator überhöh.
Damit eben auch entsprechend ein größeres Signal von einer Gravitationswelle erzeugt. Das heißt, die Advanced, äh, Detektoren erfahren und äh demnächst auch Advanced Wirgo,
haben. Äh wir nennen das Fabrik Peru Resonatoren, weil es liegen ja Haare, optische Resenatoren sind, äh die die heißen äh Fabrik Peroresenatoren,
Es sind also Detektoren äh mit Fabrik Peru Resonatoren in den Armen und Duell Recycling.
Das heißt sowohl Power als auch Signal Recycling. Das ist das ist also die ganze optische Konfiguration.
Der erste Ausbau von Leigo und Wirgo hatte das nicht. Ähm hatte das Single-Recycling nicht, weil.
Gesamtsystem zu komplex war. Man hatte noch keine Regelsignale. Man hatte keine Möglichkeiten, äh sich Signale zu erzeugen, mit dem man das Ganze steuern kann,
und äh so sind wir dann unterschiedliche Wege gegangen. Leigo und Wirgo hatten diese Armresenatoren, aber kein Signal Recycling.
Und äh wir haben gesagt, okay, äh wir haben schon Erfahrung mit Single Recycling aus Garching. Wir verfolgen dann diesen Aspekt, äh, Power und Single Recycling, das ist,
weil es uns aber auch zu kompliziert ist, lassen wir die Resenatoren in den Armen we.
Wenn diese ganzen Resonatoren so toll sind, oder aber wir vorhin festgestellt haben, dass äh auch nur ein weiterer Spiegel irgendwo gleich wieder thermisches Rauschen dazu bringt, also wie, wie passt das denn jetzt äh zusammen? Auf der einen Seite ist Spiegeln toll. Auf der anderen Seite ist.
Pielen gefährlich, warum ist es an der einen Stelle ein Problem, aber an der anderen Stelle nicht.
Da muss man ein bisschen weiter ins Detail gucken, also letztendlich das, was an der Stelle der höchsten Empfindlichkeit passiert, ist natürlich am allerwichtigsten,
wenn ich ähm armen Resonatoren habe, dann sind das diese Armresenatoren und jede Störung in den Armresenatoren wirkt sich mit der Überhöhung des Feldes darin entsprechend auf den Ausgang aus,
Das heißt, alles, was äh in in äh Leigo und Wirgo außerhalb dieser Resonatoren der Armresenatorin ist, ist schon mal um Faktor, von sagen wir mal hundert äh geringer. Wirkt sich geringer aus.
Bei Geo ist es jetzt so, dass diese Faltung äh oder die Nichteffizienz dieser Faltung ist ein bisschen das Zusammenspiel unglücklicher äh Umstände,
das kommt eben, wie du schon gesagt hast, äh, zum einen, daher, dass ich die die, dass ich die Beiträge alle aufsummieren muss,
jetzt ist es eben äh zweimal der Fernespiegel, einmal der Narre,
Am Fernspiegel ist es dummerweise auch noch alles äh das heißt äh ich nehme exakt die gleichen Rauschbeiträge doppelt. Das heißt, der zählt doppelt. Ich musste nicht nur Quadratisch antieren.
Dann äh kommt noch eine Komplikation dazu, die wir auch lange Zeit nicht auf dem Schirm hatten,
Auf den Fernen spiegel treffen jetzt ja zwei Strahlen. Zum einen der vom Strahlteiler rausgehende, trifft den Fernspiel, dann geht er zum Nahenspiegel und dann kommt der Strahl wieder zurück und trifft nochmal auf den Fernspiegel,
Das heißt, da treffen sich jetzt zwei Strahlen unter einem Winkel.
Die verursachen einen Streifenmuster auf diesem Spiegel und dieses Streifenmuster erhöht nochmal den Beitrag des thermischen Rauschens.
Da geht es ein bisschen zu weit ins Detail, aber das sind also das, dass wir bei GO sechshundert, durch die Faltung nichts gewonnen haben, ist so ein bisschen das Zusammenspiel, unglücklicher Umstände, generell ist es schon so, dass die Resenatoren,
die Empfindlichkeit erhöhen.
Und jetzt haben wir also die gesamte Konfiguration vom Kern Interverometer von zum Beispiel Advanced Libo haben wir jetzt ganz abgehandelt und jetzt kommt der Strahl da also raus.
Und jetzt könnte ich ihn auf die Fotodiode schicken. Jetzt könnte ich ihn also auf den Fotodetektor,
mit dem ich dann die Helligkeitsänderungen mir angucke, die von einer Gravitationswelle verursacht werden.
Nun ist es aber so, wir hatten ja vorhin gesagt, die Spiegel müssen außerordentlich gut poliert sein,
damit die zurückkommenden Strahlen sich perfekt äh auslöschen können oder in unserem Fall jetzt, wo wir gar nicht perfekter Auswärtsspiel wollen,
einen schönen, runden, Gausstrahl, schönen, runden Laserstrahl, mit, sagen wir mal, fünf Millimeter machen. Nur sind die Spiegel aber nicht perfe,
die sind schon sehr, sehr gut.
Die Abweichung, also damit die Strahlen immer wieder in sich selbst zurückreflektiert werden, sind die Concards, die haben eine Kugelform und die Abweichung von dieser Kugelform sind im Subnanometerbereich, etwa null Komma drei, null Komma fünf Nanometer
Abweichung von der Kugelform. Das ist schon sehr, sehr gut. Aber noch nicht gut genug. Die beiden zurückkommenden Strahlen.
Adieren oder löschen sich nicht zu einem schönen, sauberen, gaußförmigen, runden Laserstrahl aus. Da sind, äh, wie wir das nennen, noch höhere Moden dabei, also noch so ein, so ein bisschen Kartoffelacker, äh, kommt da raus.
Äh das.
Dieses Licht, was uns keine Information gibt, was kein äh keine Änderung auf die Gravitationswelle, kann keine.
Einseitige Änderung auf die Kombinationswelle hat.
Hat natürlich auch Rauschen. Das heißt, der Effekt ist, es trägt zwar vernachlässigbar zum Signal bei, aber es regnen, es wäre zum Rauschen bei. Das gefällt uns natürlich nicht.
Das heißt, wir wollen dieses Licht rausfiltern. Also haben wir am Ausgang nochmal einen optischen Resonator wieder ein Filter.
Den nennen wir diesmal den Output Mode Cleaner, also so wie wir den Modenkliena am Eingang hatten, haben wir am Ausgang jetzt auch ein.
Und filtern dieses Ganze nicht äh Rund, Gausförmige, Licht äh filtern wir we.
Wird einfach wieder rausgeschleudert.
Es wird alles wieder äh rausgefiltert und reflektiert. Und das, was durch dieses Filter, durch diesen Output Model hat dann noch durchkommt, das geht jetzt auf eine Fototiode,
und da wird dann tatsächlich die Kombinationsfelder gemessen. Jetzt müssen wir also am Ende angekommen,
und einen Trick, der jetzt in jüngster Zeit auch äh nach Vorarbeiten von äh uns hier bei Geo sechshundert, äh der jetzt überall eingebaut ist.
Ich hatte ja vorhin erwähnt, dass Schrotrauschen. Also die die Nullpunktfluktuation des äh dunklen, elektromagnetischen Zustands, das Vakuumrauschens,
was überall ist,
was auch zum Ausgang reingeht. Also draußen ist ja dunkel, scheint ja kein Licht rein, aber trotzdem diese diese Vakuumfluktation, die Fluktuation, das elektromagnetischen Feldes gehen da rein, werden vom Interferometer reflektiert.
Weil das in der Richtung sowie der Laserstrahl wieder zum Laser zurückreflektiert wurde vom Intervermeter,
wir werden die Felder, die ich zum Ausgang reinschicke, auch vom Interviewmeter wieder reflektiert und überlagern sich dann auf der Fotodiode.
Also dies Vakuumrauschen, was am Interpharometer reflektiert wird, das sorgt mir äh letztendlich für das äh Schrotrauschen auf der Fotodiode.
Da kann ich mal was gegen tun. Ich kann das modifizieren. Das nennt man dann äh gequetschte Zustände oder.
Das heißt, äh ich erzeuge mir,
einen Zustand, in dem das Rauschen ähm in der Phase zum Beispiel ein bisschen verringert ist, auf Kosten der Amplituten des Amplitudenrauschens.
Damit kann ich mir dieses Schrotrauschen nochmal ein bisschen reduzieren. Das ist eine Technik,
die schon in den Neunzigern vorgeschlagen wurde, die dann relativ lange gebraucht hat, um erstmal entwickelt zu werden von den von der Technik, von der technischen Seite her,
wurden auch äh viele Vorarbeiten in Hannover geleistet. Wir haben,
diese Technik des gequetschten Lichtes jetzt seit zweitausendzehn hier in bei GO sechshundert am Start zweitausendzehn haben wir ein,
hier eingebaut und haben jetzt äh im äh letzten Jahr ähm eine Verbesserung der Empfindlichkeit, um Fantor zwei Dampf erreich.
Also, ich muss zugeben, dass mit dem gequetschten Licht habe ich jetzt noch nicht verstanden. Was wird denn da jetzt gequetscht? Also, äh, was ich jetzt mitgenommen habe, ist folgendes. Wir haben jetzt natürlich zahlreiche Stufen äh.
Durchschritten, in der man alles Mögliche getan hat, um Störungen zu minimieren. Sie sind natürlich immer da.
Bis hin zum allerletzten Schritt, bevor wir überhaupt die eigentliche Messung des Lichtsignals vornehmen, nochmal dieser Modler, der irgendwie,
fehlgeleitete Teil äh Strahlen einfach rausschleudert, sodass wir an einem relativ klaren,
äh differenzsignal dieser ganzen, dieses Laserweg sozusagen nagen können. Und trotzdem gibt es jetzt hier nochmal einen Rauschen, was einfach auftrifft,
weil das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau, also.
Genau, so ist es. Ähm wir haben uns jetzt also um die ganzen Rauschbeiträge ordentlich gekümmert und haben die alle runtergedrückt, so gut es geht,
wenn wir uns jetzt angucken, wodurch sind wir denn bei verschiedenen Frequenzen limitiert,
dann stellen wir fest, dass speziell zu den hohen Frequenzen, ähm, aber auch so, also die, die.
Sind ja die Hohen, also von welchen Frequenzen reden wir denn da jetzt.
Die die Empfindlichkeitskurve, die wir angeben, ist ja in Wirklichkeit eine Rauschkurve, das heißt, wir geben an, dass Gravitationswellen, Äquivalente, Eigenrauschen des Detektors als Funktion der Frequenz,
und äh das hat immer so eine äh,
so eine uförmige Form. Das heißt, zu niedrigen Frequenzen hin steigt das Rauschen stark an,
und das sind das sind sehr, sehr vielfältige Gründe, sehr viele technische Gründe, ähm zum Beispiel, dass äh Rauschen der Aktuatoren, die wir für die Laser, äh, für die Spiegelorientierung verwenden,
sehr, sehr viele zum Teil auch noch durchkommen, das seismisches Rauschen, das thermische Rauschen, der Aufhängung, das thermische Rauschen der Spiegel auch.
Also egal, was man alles rausfindet, es bleibt einfach trotzdem noch.
Es bleibt natürlich immer noch was übrig. Ansonsten äh wäre man einfach nur empfindlicher und würde wieder auf einem neuen Rauschen auf.
Ja, okay.
Das äh also diese Vielzahl der technischen Rauschbeiträge, wenn wir jetzt mal von etwa ins Liko, dem empfindlichsten Detektor sprechen, äh das geht so, sagen wir mal, bis dreißig, vierzig, fünfzig Hertz,
dann äh flach äh nach dieser Empfindlichkeit, also im im Bucket, wie wir sagen, also unten im Tal dieses Uhs,
ist es durch Quantenrauschen, also durch das Licht selbst und auch durch thermisches Rauschen der Spiegelbeschichtung limitiert.
Das geht, ähm, sagen wir mal, bis zu ein paar hundert Hertz und äh oberhalb,
Da spielt jetzt die Bandbreite dieser Single Recycling äh ähm der Resenators oder auch der Armresenatoren, wieder eine Rolle,
da geht äh das Rauschen wieder hoch. Letztendlich war das Signal runtergeht, weil das dann nicht mehr Resonanz überhöht wird.
Und da in dem hohen Frequenzbereich, also oberhalb von einigen hundert Herz, sind wir durch die Quantennatur,
der elektrischen Felder limitiert.
Und wenn man's runterkocht, kommt es durch das am Ausgang reflektierte Elektromagnetische Feld.
In welchem Frequenzbereich sind wir denn jetzt am besten? Also das äh ist mir noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar geworden und vor allem an welchem Frequenzbereich sind wir eigentlich am meisten interessiert? Wo sind denn die Gravitationsfällen.
Ja, er die einfacher zu beantwortende Frage ist, äh wo denn die Empfindlichkeit am besten ist,
Ähm äh das ist äh bei ein paar hundert Hertz, hängt natürlich vom Detektor ab und hängt auch davon ab, wie man den Detektor dann äh konfiguriert,
von den Spiegelpositionen, zum Beispiel auch mit dem äh Single Recyclingspiegel kann ich das Ganze so ein bisschen abstimmen.
Aber diese U-Kurve, die sich quasi so über diese Frequenzen äh Bereiche äh legen, sagt halt aus im niedrigsten Bereich, ist es gut, dann ist es schlecht und dann ist es wieder gut. Anders.
Ey, andersrum andersrum. Äh das ist das exivalente Rauschen, was wir da.
Ah okay, also.
Das Rauschen bei niedrigen Frequenzen ist ho.
Hoch, dann wird's gut und danach wird's wieder doof. Okay, gut, das heißt, der Sweetspot ist so in der Mitte und äh wo der genau ist, hängt dann jeweils von der technischen Apparatur ab, aber im Idealfall ist das dann auch der Frequenzbereich, in dem man Gravitationsfällen äh detektieren kann.
Ja, das hängt von den Gravitationsfällen noch ein bisschen ab. Also im Augenblick äh ist der, äh, ist der Sweetspot, so bei ein paar hundert Hertz, ähm, zweihundert Hertz, hundertzweihundert Hertz.
Und die Gravitationswellen, wo man die am besten detektieren kann, hängt natürlich auch von der Verfügbarkeit der Gravitationswälder,
Also es hat ja praktisch jeder ähm der Zuhörer, nämlich mal an die Form des Gravitationswellens, Signals, des ersten Gravitationswellens, Signals,
gesehen. Das ist so ein Jerb. Ähm die Frequenz genau, der die Frequenz nimmt zu, aber auch die Amplitude nimmt zu.
Nun denkt man natürlich, äh ja, ähm da, wo es am größten ist, kann ich's auch am leichtesten detektieren. Das stimmt aber nicht so ganz,
denn bei den niedrigen Frequenzen ändert sich die Frequenz auch weniger schnell. Das heißt, bei dem niedrigen Frequenzen hält sich das System viel länger auf,
das führt dazu.
Dass die Signalamplitude bei den niedrigen Frequenzen höher ist, als äh die die spektrale Dichte letztendlich bei niedrigen Frequenzen höher ist als am Ende des Vorgan.
Das heißt, bei welchen Frequenzen ich die Signale am besten Detektieren kann, hängt nicht nur vom Detektor, sondern auch von Signal.
Voll Signal ab. Okay. Und so und und dieses Bub, was wir haben, das ist ja sozusagen die auch schon vorher mathematisch vorher gesagte, ähm Kennung, quasi von zwei schwarzen Döchern, die umeinander herum äh tanzen und.
Genau, generell von zwei kompakten Objekten, bei den neutronen Sternen sah es ja ganz genau so aus.
Was hat es dann auch dieselbe Form gehabt.
Es hat die selbe Form gehabt, das war nur sehr viel länger, ähm weil ähm weil der die Energieabstrahlung wegen der geringeren Masse äh geringer ist und äh im Gegensatz zu dem ersten Signal, was etwa null Komma zwei Sekunden gedauert hat.
Äh konnten wir das neutronen Stern, die Neutronstern Merger, äh über etwa fünfzig Sekunden, knapp eine Minute.
Okay, also unterscheidet sich eher in der Dauer, als in der, in der, in der Art und Weise der Ausprägung. Das heißt, der Nachteil, dass man in den niedrigen Frequenzen mehr Rauschen hat,
wird dadurch ein bisschen kompensiert, dass sich das äh zu messende Signal in diesem Bereich zeitlich länger ausdehnt und man dann sozusagen da über die Zeit sozusagen,
mehr ignorieren.
Genau für dieses spezielle Signal. Nun gibt es natürlich noch viele andere Signale bei Super Norwehr, wäre das ganz anders. Äh da erwartet man, dass Maximum so bei einem knappen Kiloherz ähm und äh auch ähm sehr viel ähm,
sehr viel kürzer, also so, dass man jetzt nicht sehr lange in einem Bereich integrieren kann.
Das heißt, das wird schwierig, weil man hat da schon wieder viel Rauschen, je nach dem wie die Detektor so angelegt ist.
Es kommt drauf an, wie der Detektor angelegt ist, ganz genau.
Das heißt, man könnte im Prinzip auch sich einen dick
bauen, der, äh, wenn man irgendwann mal Schnauze voll hat, von schwarzen Löchern, Neutronstern, weil es ja langweilig haben wir jetzt irgendwie äh am laufenden Meter gesehen. Man will jetzt einfach mal ein paar Supernova äh äh detektieren, könnte man darüber nachdenken, sollte man sowas finanzieren wollen. Ein
äh Detektor zu bauen, der sich speziell auf diesen Frequenzbereich äh stürzt und daraufhin optimiert ist, da weniger Rausch.
Genau, da wird auch drüber nachgedacht. Ähm, es gibt nicht nur die Supernorve, im höherfrequenten Bereich, die neutronen Sterne.
Das, was da im niederfrequenten Bereich passiert, ist ja, dass äh Zusammenspiralen von zwei Punktmassen sozusagen,
Das ist in dem Sinne relativ langweilig, weil sich das äh gut modellieren lässt. Äh man kennt die Masse der neue Drohnensterne, da ist nicht viel neues interessanter,
wird es dann,
wenn die neutronen Sterne sich so nahe kommen, dass es ähm Titel deformations, also dass es Deformation, durch die gegenseitige Gravitationswirkung der Neutronensterne gibt, weil einem das dann Aufschluss,
darüber gibt, wie sich ein Notronstern überhaupt verhält. Und noch spannender wird es dann,
wenn die miteinander verschmolzen sind, nach dem Merchor, wenn es dann die Eigenmoden dieses neugebildeten,
neutronen Sterns und eventuell dann auch eine super massive Neutronsternsterne begrenzte Lebensdauer hat und dann zu einem schwarzen Loch klaviert kommt.
Das spielt sich alles im Bereich weniger Kiloherz ab. So zwei bis vier Kilo Herzogenau, weiß man das nicht und das hängt auch davon ab, äh wie,
wie verhält sich so ein Neutronenstern denn überhaupt? Äh wie wie zäh ist der zum Beispiel und sowas.
Vielleicht äh ist an dieser Stelle nochmal einen ganz guten, kleinen äh Überblick zu geben, was wir denn derzeit jetzt haben. Also wir haben GO sechshundert. Wir haben,
Leigo in zweifacher Ausführung in den USA, also äh Advanced, also ein zwei Standorten
äh Leigo, dann ist in Italien dazugekommen, in Japan kommt jetzt Kagra, dazu ist aber technisch noch nicht ganz fertig, wenn ich das jetzt richtig rausgehört habe oder noch nicht zu Ende optimiert.
Kargra hat jetzt gerade zusammen mit Geo sechshundert, noch so in einem Nachschwinger von äh dem letzten Observation Run. Also wir haben ähm wir haben jetzt drei sogenannte Obsuvation Runs absolviert,
das fing zweitausendfünfzehn an mit dem Nummer eins, wo wir auch gleich zu Beginn die Detektion hatten.
In gegen Ende des zweiten Opsovation Runs ist dann mit eingestiegen,
und es war geplant, jetzt am Ende des dritten Observation Runs, das Cargra mit einsteigt. Kargra ist ein japanischer Detektor,
L-förmig, drei Kilometer Armlänge, unterirdisch gebaut, also in einem Berg sozusagen.
Geplant mit äh gekühlten, tiefgekühlten Safirspiegeln zu laufen. Ähm bisher ähm sind die Spiegel allerdings noch bei Zimmertemperatur,
und es war geplant, dass Cargra jetzt am Ende von dem Obsova Nummer drei noch mit einsteigt.
Dazu hat man sich geeinigt, dass das passieren soll, wenn eine bestimmte Empfindlichkeitsschwelle überschritten wird. Die Empfindlichkeitsschwelle lag in etwa bei der Empfindlichkeit von Geo sechshundert.
Und die Japaner waren auch auf einem guten Weg, aber Korona kam dazwischen. Und äh der Nummer drei wurde dann,
vorzeitig abgebrochen, sodass die Japaner erstmal keine Gelegenheit hatten damit teilzunehmen, sodass Geo sechshundert, was,
durch Corona durch, weiter sechshundert ist sehr hochgradig automatisiert, wir können das eigentlich von überall, sprich auch von zu Hause aus bedienen und betreiben,
so dass wir, trotz Corona Krise dann mit dem Japanern zusammen noch einen kurzen Datenlauf machen konnten.
Diese Opservation Runs sozusagen so zeitlich äh klar determinierte äh Mess ähm Kampagnen,
an dem dann möglichst alle teilnehmen, weil wenn die Gravitationswelle kommt, dann ist sie ja überall messbar. Sie geht ja durch die ganze Welt.
Wenn die Gravitationswelle kommt, ist sie im Prinzip überall messbar, das hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen von der relativen Ausrichtung, der Gravitationswellen, Detektoren zur Welle a.
Und auf einer Kugeloberfläche wie der Erde ist es natürlich nicht möglich, dass alle die gleiche Orientierung haben.
Das heißt, zwangsläufig haben die Detektoren zueinander eine unterschiedliche Ausrichtung.
Was dann selbst bei identischer Empfindlichkeit der Messinstrumente selbst zu unterschiedlich starken Signalen führen würde. Das muss nicht ein Nachteil, muss nicht nur ein Nachteil sein.
Ähm es war, im Gegenteil, sogar so, dass ähm bei dem neutronen Stern Merchor siebzehn null acht siebzehn ähm,
Tatsache, dass in Wirgo ein sehr, sehr geringes Signal nur detektiert wurde, obwohl ähm Wirgo von der Empfindlichkeit her gut genug war.
Die das Pointing, also die Richtung, aus der das Signal gekommen sein muss.
Sehr stark verbessern konnte. Einfach, weil man gesagt hat, wir hat äh das Signal nur sehr, sehr schwach gesehen. Das heißt, es muss aus dem toten Winkel äh des Detektors gekommen sein,
wenn die Gravitationsfälle praktisch unter fünfundvierzig Grad in diesen Öffnungswinkel äh einfällt, dann macht sie in beiden Armen den gleichen Effekt,
und den dann hat man also kein Differenziellen Effekt, wir messen aber nur differenzielle Effekte, dementsprechend ist das Instrument für die Richtung unempfindlich.
Wenn wir also wissen, wir hätten ein Signal sehen, müssen, weil die Empfindlichkeit eben gut genug war zu dem Zeitpunkt. Wir sehen aber keins,
kann man daraus rückfolgern, äh dass es aus der Richtung gekommen sein muss. Was ich dann auch äh später bestätigt.
Ja, also für zukünftige Kampagnen ist es sozusagen richtig gut,
dass man jetzt auf, was haben wir jetzt, also mit einer GO sechshundert mal dazu äh messen, haben wir dann fünf Detektoren
äh am Start und die alle im Wesentlichen ja so im selben Frequenzbereich äh äh Wildern mit Abstüffungen vermutlich.
Ja, das ist leider nicht der Fall. Äh die.
Der Sprung, der im von der ersten Generation, also Leige und Wirgo auf Entwarnungslage und Advanced Wirgo,
passiert ist und der dann letztendlich auch zu dem plötzlichen Detektieren von Gravitationswellen geführt hat, ist die Verbesserung im niederfrequenten Bereich.
Initial Leigo, die erste Generation hatte einfach Pendelaufhängungen für die Spiegel. Und dementsprechend bei niedrigen Frequenzen eine sehr schlechte Empfindlichkeit.
Im Advanced, Leigo ist jetzt sozusagen ein Upgrade, der Geotechnologie, der Geo-Spiegelaufhängungen eingebaut worden, in dem Fall vierfach äh Aufhängungen, die von Glasgow bereitgestellt wurden,
Und das war mit ein wesentlicher äh Schritt für die niederfrequente Empfindlichkei.
Gerade die Empfindlichkeit hat die Detektion ermöglich.
Aber die die sind nieder äh Möglichkeit, die ist auch in Wirkung und auch in jetzt auch vorhanden.
Cargra ist bei niedrigen Frequenzen noch sehr schlecht. Ähm. Soll, soll besser.
Also nicht so sehr jetzt wie es jetzt stand heute ist, aber so grundsätzlich will dann sie alle im selben Bereich oder werden das zumindest sehr bald äh tun. Sprich, die sind eigentlich dafür prädestiniert,
dieselben Ereignisse, alle von in einem anderen Blickpunkt aus zu beobachten, mit vielleicht kleinen Unterschieden. Brauche ich eigentlich hinaus will ist.
Es gibt ja noch ein sechstes äh Projekt, was oder genau genommen gibt, sogar noch ein ein siebtes und ein achtes äh äh Projekt, aber das habe ich ja in der letzten Sendung hier auch schon ausführlich äh besprochen. Das ist Lisa, das äh,
im Weltall, dasselbe Prinzip verfolgen soll. Dort sollen dann halt drei Satelliten, da haben wir dann wieder das äh,
ja, das Geodreieck ähm.
Äh das soll dann, glaube ich, zweitausend, zweitausendvierunddreißig oder so in Betrieb äh gehen, also ist noch ein bisschen hin. Äh zum Zeitpunkt des,
Gesprächs war aber gerade diese Forschungsmission gestartet worden. Dieser Passfeinder, wo die Technik ja sozusagen überhaupt erstmal ausprobiert wurde. Was hat sich denn da gezeigt,
und,
wie wird Lisa diesen Erdverbund von Gravitationsweltendetektoren ergänzen oder blickt dieser in eine ganz andere Welt.
Erstmal ist das natürlich noch ein bisschen hin, äh bis Lisa fliegen wird und messen wird. Äh bis dahin wird sich die Technik auf der Erde ja auch noch weiterentwickeln,
der nächste Schritt, der Nächste, Detektor, der auf der Erde ähm jetzt schon konkret in Planung ist, ist äh Leigo India,
ähm die es gab ja mal drei Leinge Detektoren ein im Vakuumsystem in Luis Jana und zwei in äh in Washington in Handford.
Ähm da gab's einen zwei Kilometer und einen vier Kilometer Detektor und für die äh nächste Generation, die zweite nämlich, die jetzige,
wurde entschieden, dass der zwei Kilometer Detektor dort nicht wieder eingebaut wird,
sondern, dass stattdessen mit der Leigo Hardware ein dritter Detektor anderswo aufgebaut wird. Zunächst war Australien im Gespräch,
da gab es aber Finanzierungsschwierigkeiten. Und jetzt wird das Ganze in Indien gebaut. Es gibt da eine Zeit, da fangen die Bauarbeiten jetzt gerade an,
Da wird also ein Dritter, Advanced, Ligo Detector aufgebaut werden. Das wird erstmal der nächste Schritt im in diesem Netzwerk,
dann ähm nähern wir uns äh schon so den äh dreißiger Jahren und wir erwarten nicht, dass die Infrastrukturen der jetzigen Instrumente langlebig genug sind,
um da noch ordentlich Perspektive zu geben. Das heißt, wir denken jetzt auch über die nächste Generation der Erdgebunden der Gravitationswelle. Detektoren nach,
da sind dann die Stichworte in Europa, das Einsteinteeliskop und äh Cosmic Explorer. Also das das wäre erstmal der.
Pfad, wie wir mit der Erdgebundenen äh Gravitationswellen, Astronomie weitermachen, ähm mit den gleichen,
Frequenzbereichen, also wieder der Akustikbereich, das fällt ja die jetzige Empfindlichkeit der äh Gravitationswellen Detektoren,
fällt ja mit dem Hörvermögen, dass Menschen äh sehr gut überein.
Und da wird auch die Zukunft weiterhin gehen. Wir versuchen das dann noch ein bisschen auszuweiten mit dem Einsteinteleskop äh zum Beispiel zu niedrigeren Frequenzen bis zu zwei, drei Herz runter,
aber der Frequenzbereich der erdgebundenen bleibt im Wesentlichen darauf eingeschrän.
Sehr viel weiter runter kann man da auch nicht gehen, weil einfach die Störquellen gegen die wir nichts machen können auf der Erde zu stark vertreten sind. Da bewegt sich zu viel,
und irgendwann ist man auch mit der Pendelaufhängung über die wir vorhin geredet hatten, limitiert,
da kann man noch so gut filtern, die gravitative Wechselwirkung. Also wenn ich, wenn ich auf der, wenn ich in der Nähe des Spiegels eine Masse bewege, dann zieht diese Masse den Spiegel natürlich an.
Und äh das passiert ständig. Die Erdoberfläche bewegt sich. Es laufen ständig, sei es Mische wählen, äh durch die Erde, auf der Erdoberfläche entlang,
und diese äh Newton Gravitation, also das nennen wir das auch, New Tonian Neues. Äh das kann man nicht abschirmen.
Also wenn ich jetzt die ganze Zeit mit einem Paket Goldbarren in der Nähe des Spiegels herum wädeln würde, dann würde man das schon merken.
Das würde man auf jeden Fall merken, äh das ist nebenbei bemerkt, auch eine der Kalibrationsmethoden, wie wir die Gravitationswellen, Detektoren kalibrieren.
Auch erst mit Goldbarren.
Da nicht mit Gold waren. Äh aber ähm mit, also es gibt da verschiedene Methoden. Zum einen kalibrieren wir die Instrumente dadurch, dass wir die äh Aktuator Wirkung auf die Spiegel genau kalibrieren.
Dann haben wir, ähm, wir nennen das Foto und Drives, also Fotonen, Druck äh Aktuatoren,
wir äh leuchten, zum Beispiel bei Geo auf den äh auf den Spiegel am Ende des Nordabends, leuchten wir mit einem Laserstrahl, leicht anderer Wellenlänge, damit das nicht stört,
und wir modulieren dessen Leistung. Das ist ein Laserstrahl mit etwa einem Watt und der wird an dem Spiegel reflektiert und der Fotonendruck. Also der Lichtdruck. Wir reden hier nicht über thermische Effekte, wir bringen über Lichtdruck.
Der bewegt den Spiegel.
Wenn man die Laserleistung und die Modulationstiefe kennt, kann man sich sehr leicht ausrechnen, wie groß die Spiegelbewegung sein muss. Man kann auf diese Weise sehr akkurat den äh Ausgang des kalibrieren.
Dass es letztendlich dann nur dadurch begrenzt, wie genau kann ich denn meine Laserleistung messen.
Und äh da, da gibt es sogar Anstrengungen, äh der vom äh Nist, also dem äh.
Der, der amerikanischen äh PTB sozusagen, die Standards entwickeln.
Messgeräte für die Laserleistung zu verbessern, damit die Gravitation zur Intektorin besser kalibriert werden können. Und ein weiterer, eine weitere Möglichkeit, die zu kalibrieren ist, dass ich Massen in der Nähe der Spiegel,
bewege. Rotiere,
Das heißt, ich nehme mir Massen, ich nehme mehr Scheiben, in denen ich eine gewisse Massenverteilung habe, rotiere, die schnell und die gravitative Wechselwirkung mit dem Spiegel bewegt dann den Spiegel, da kann ich mir auch ganz genau ausrechnen, wie viel das ist.
Und kann auch auf die Weise den Detektor kalibrieren.
Gab's nicht auch noch irgendwas mit Heizspiralen.
Das ist aber nicht zum äh Kalibrieren, das ist zum äh Korrigieren der Spiegel,
Ich hatte ja erwähnt, dass die Spiegel zwar wunderbar geschliffen sind und eine sehr, sehr schöne Oberfläche haben von der Form her, aber,
Die Oberflächenform weicht von dem, was man gerne hätte, immer noch ein kleines bisschen a.
Bei unseren Spiegeln ist es zum Beispiel so, dass äh die leicht falsche Krümmungsradien haben,
so dass die von den beiden Armen zurückkommen, denn Strahlen etwas unterschiedliche Durchmesser hätten.
Dann klappt das mit dem Auslöschen am Ausgang natürlich nicht mehr so gut.
Und wir haben hinter dem Nordendspiegel ein äh eine Heizspirale, eine Ringheizer,
mit dem wir die Rückseite des Spiegels aufheizen können und dann über die thermische Verbiegung können wir den Krümmungsradius der Vorderseite steuern.
Haben wir auf beiden Seiten auch nochmal, sodass wir da ähm seitliche Effekte, Astigmatismus auch noch kompensieren können.
Okay, ich wollte jetzt gar nicht so sehr in die äh äh Spiegeldetails äh zurückgehen, sondern eigentlich mal versuchen, so ein bisschen ähm einerseits so ein bisschen hier äh auf die den Endspurt zu äh raten, aber andererseits auch eben auch nochmal so das große Bild aufzumach.
Ja, also.
Also, das Einstein, wir haben.
Genau, ähm von der Entwicklung der Detektoren her ähm wird es also dann in den dreißiger Jahren, in den späten Dreißigern, frühen Vierziger,
Jahren auf die dritte Generation hinauslaufen. Wir müssen mal sehen, wie lange die Infrastruktur der jetzigen Generation noch hält, aber der Plan ist,
neue Geräte zu bauen. Das Einsteinteleskop in Europa,
da ist angedacht, ein unterirdischen Detektor zu bauen, gleichzeitig ist Dreieck, zehn Kilometer Armlänge, in der Tiefe von ungefähr zweihundert Metern, es gibt zwei Kandidaten, Standorte,
Sardinien oder dass drei Länder, Eckbelgien, Niederlande, Deutschland, äh so die Aachener gegen Limburg hinten.
Ähm bisher auf der holländischen Seite angedacht.
Und da ist es äh das Ziel, die Empfindlichkeit nochmal, um eine Größenordnung zu steigern gegenüber dem Design der jetzigen Detektor.
Da kann man natürlich sagen, äh jetzt habt ihr doch aber schon so viele schwarze Löcher gesehen, du hast da auch mal genug, warum wird er denn noch mehr sehen, aber letztendlich geht es halt dann um Gravitationswellen, Astronomie.
Wir haben, was wir jetzt im Wesentlichen gemacht haben, die Gravitationswellenastronomie fing natürlich schon ein bisschen an, insbesondere mit dem neutronen Sternenmercher, aber in erster Linie waren es ja Detektionen,
aber das Gravitationswellen, Astronomie, Zeitalter fängt eben erst an,
wir wollen damit Details von Prozessen untersuchen können. Wir wollen damit das innere von neutronen Sternen erforschen können. Ähm wir wollen,
auch ähm glitsches, inneutronisch, ja. Man kann damit Astroseismologie machen. Wir wissen,
dass die neutronen Sterne äh leichte Glitsches haben, das wissen wir von den Pulsaren, weil sich die Pulsardzeiten, also die Umdrehungsfrequenz dieser neutronen Sterne,
geringfügig ändern. Äh, da müssen irgendwelche Sternenbeben, die auch Gravitationswellen imitieren müssen, hinterherstecken.
Aber auch ähm durch eine Vielzahl von schwarzen Löchern, die wir mit der dritten Generation beobachten können werden. Wir werden,
Mit der Empfindlichkeit der dritten Generation im Wesentlichen alle,
jeden einzelnen im gesamten Universum, im gesamten sichtbaren Universum detektieren können, zumindest bis dahin, wo wir denken, dass es äh überhaupt schwarze Löcher schon gegeben hat.
Da drüber kann man dann auch in die Kosmologie einsteigen.
Was für eine Historie hat das Universum, wie äh sieht das mit der Entwicklung von schwarzen Löchern aus.
Zu zu großen Rotverschiebungen von bis zu hundert.
Also da, da eröffnet sich dann ein ähm ein weites Feld, der Präzisionsgravitationswellen Astronomie. Wo wir jetzt gerade erst am Anfang stehen.
Das war ja auch schon so ein bisschen die Perspektive am am Anfang. Das, was man halt vielleicht auch nochmal klar machen sollte. Seid ihr in den Raum,
qualifiziert blicken. War es ja immer der Elektromagnetismus, der uns sozusagen die Information gebracht hat in Form von,
äh Licht oder in Form von äh Gammastrahlen und also all diese ganzen Frequenzbereiche, die wir sozusagen mit allen möglichen äh Teleskopen und Sensoren abgefangen haben,
nur die Gravitationswellen tragen einfach die Information nochmal von
ganz woanders her, auch aus äh Regionen, die wir nicht sehen können oder die durch so viel anderes Licht äh verdeckt sind, ja, immer das Problem in die Milchstraße reinzuschauen, so viele Sterne, alles hell irgendwie, sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig, da äh,
reinzufühlen und genau festzustellen, wie sich das eigentlich aus. Wir haben eine Vorstellung davon, wie unsere Galaxis aussieht, aber da wir sozusagen von innen reinschauen, es ist äh
ist es eben sehr schwierig, also Gravitationsfällen sind einfach nochmal so ein ganz anderer Sensor, ein ganz anderes äh,
ja, eine ganz andere Wahrnehmungsoption, die es ja so noch nicht gegeben hat. Was lässt sich denn jetzt so.
Zu sehen oder was was ist zumindest im Bereich des des des Fühlbahn oder oder Denkbarn, welche äh Erkenntnisbereiche von der Gravitationswellen, Astronomie besonders profitieren
können, wird es uns dabei äh,
helfen die Größe des Universums genauer zu äh bestimmen, wissen wir mehr über äh dunkle Materie, wo kann das alles noch rein,
fliegen.
Ob wir auf dem Gebiet der dunklen Materie da sehr viel weiterkommen, bezweifle ich, weiß ich auch nicht genau, ähm aber,
die ganzen anderen äh Aspekte hast du im Wesentlichen schon angesprochen. All das, was wir so nicht sehen können,
entweder, weil es überhaupt keine elektromagnetischen Wellen imitiert. Über schwarze Löcher etwas zu lernen, ähm ist im elektromagnetischen Bereich eben schwierig, weil sie wenig imitieren, wenn überhaupt.
Auch in die Frühzeit des Universums, in die ersten dreihundertachtzigtausend Jahre nach dem Urknall zurückzuschauen,
ist mit elektromagnetischer Strahlung schwierig, kann man nur indirekte Schlussfolgerungen ziehen,
ähm ist das Universum war die ersten dreihundertachtzigtausend Jahre einfach zu heiß. Es war praktisch ein hell leuchtender Nebel,
das was wir eben jetzt als den Mikrowellenhintergrund sehen.
Die Gravitationswellen konnten sich schon sehr, sehr früh frei ausbreiten, sodass wir da eventuell auch über die Frühzeiten des Universums was erfahren können, also über die die Zeiten,
jenseits des äh Elektromagnetischen hinausgehen.
Hat es denn nach dem Urknall überhaupt solche Ereignisse geben können, wie wir sie jetzt messen? Also die schwarzen Löcher äh größeren Zusammenklubungen, die haben sich hal,
ich das richtig sehe zu dem Zeitpunkt ja noch überhaupt gar nicht ausgebildet, sodass ihr dann auch gar nicht so aufeinander treffen konnten.
Nein, man geht davon aus, dass äh in den Frühzeiten es keine schwarzen Löcher gab, ähm was eine zu überprüfen, die Hypothese wäre.
Ja okay.
Ähm aber in den Frühzeiten während der Phasenübergänge im frühen Universum, Inflation, da, ähm, da passiert da halt auch sehr viel. Da wurden auch Gravitationswellen imitiert.
Und in diese Zeiten kann man mit elektromagnetischer Strahlung nicht zurü.
Aber es wäre durchaus vorstellbar, dass wir irgendwann mal ein Ereignis haben, was soweit in der Zeit zurück, die also sofern von uns ist, dass wir dann wirklich nochmal ein Signal von vor, bevor das Universum durchsichtig war, äh, erhalten.
Was exakt man da erwarten kann, bin ich auch überfragt, dass es geht da mehr um den äh stochastischen Hintergrund, an Gravitationswellenstrahlung, ähnlich dem Mikrowellenhinter.
Da gibt es abhängig von den kosmologischen Modellen unterschiedliche spentrale Verteilungen, was man da erwarten kann,
und im Umkehrschluss kann man über eine Beobachtung,
der Verteilung des äh Gravitationswellen Hintergrund ist, dann auch wieder Schlussfolgerungen ziehen, was war denn los.
Verstehe. Das heißt, jetzt befinden wir uns eigentlich so ein bisschen in so einer Babyphase. Wir haben jetzt die Detektortechnik soweit ausgebaut, dass man sagen kann, okay, wenn mal was richtig krasses passiert, so, die Gravitationswellen, die dabei anfallen, die kriegen wir jetzt irgendwie gemessen,
aber damit äh nippen wir eigentlich gerade nur so ein bisschen den Schaum vom Bier und um den vollen Schluck nehmen zu können,
würde man jetzt also technologisch soweit vorankommen, alles nochmal um äh ähm immer wieder um so einen zehner Faktor alles zu verfeinern. Würden wir dann so irgendwann,
quasi so die Gravitationswellen der Gravitationswellen messen, also sozusagen so ein ein Gravitationswellenrauschen äh wahrnehmen können, an dem wir wie,
quasi das Zittern des Universums abnehmen könnten.
Naja ein Zittern des Universums ist es ja alles. Also.
Es wird eben die Raumzeit äh durch die einzelnen Ereignisse, die wir jetzt sehen, verändert, aber ja, wir werden irgendwann äh auch die Empfindlichkeit erreichen, dass wir praktisch ständig Gravitationswellen, Signale sehen,
und äh dann eben entsprechend, wenn wir was über die Einzelereignisse wissen wollen, auch die da rauspicken müssen.
Aber es nochmal ganz andere Ereignisse sind als die, die wir jetzt im Fokus haben.
Na ja, es wird, wenn man nur hinreichend empfindlich ist, ein ähm ein Hintergrund an Gravitationswellen geben, durch die Vielzahl der Ereignisse.
Also zum Beispiel so ein Supernova TV, dass man also wirklich permanent alles äh irgendwas explodiert, einfach mitbekommen würde, weil man eben in der Lage ist, dass jetzt so fein zu mess.
Also ähnlich. Ähm also man weiß ähm und da sind wir wieder beim äh Lisa ähm beim bei dem äh Lisaopservatorium,
was einen völlig anderen Frequenzbereich abdeckt, nämlich äh etwa drei Größenordnungen weiter unten, also was,
erdgebundenen im Bereich von Herz machen, das macht Lisa im Bereich von Milliarz.
Und dort wird es um die empfindlichste.
Frequenz von Lisa, was etwa bei einem Milliherz liegen wird, weiß man schon, dass es da ein Hintergrund von Signalen von weißen Zwergen geben wird, Doppelsternsysteme in der Milchstraße aus weißen Zwergen.
Die dann eine Auflösung der einzelnen nicht mehr ermöglichen. Also einfach eine Hintergrundrauschen von Gravitationswellen.
Durch die Vielzahl der Einzelereignisse. Ja, das wird spannend.
Ja
super. Ich könnte noch äh tagelang weiter fragen, aber ich glaube, ich mache jetzt hier langsam mal einen äh Punkt und werde es weiter äh beobachten, was ich äh tut,
Wann wird's denn zu diesem Einsteinteleskop voraussichtlich Entscheidungen geben, wo das ist und wann's das geben wird und überhaup.
Wir befinden uns jetzt in der Phase, wo wir versuchen auf die europäische Roadmap, auf die sogenannte zu kommen,
das ist ein Europa weites Bestreben, wir sind da mit unseren Kollegen,
Europa weit in Verbindung,
ähm die Deadline dafür wurde jetzt nochmal vom fünften Mai auf Ende September wegen Korona äh verschoben. Äh da sind wir also in dem Sinne ganz gut im Zeitplan,
äh
Deutschland ist da noch ein bisschen äh zögerlich im Augenblick aus finanziellen äh Gründen. Ähm wir werden in Deutschland erstmal die nationale Forschungsinfrastruktur, Roadmap,
in Angriff nehmen und hoffen, dass das Eisstein Teleskop da draufkriegen.
Der Zeithorizont für eine Entscheidung, an welchem Standort wird es denn jetzt gebaut,
wird vermutlich in zweitausendvierundzwanzig äh erfolgen. Auch ein klein bisschen nach hinten geschoben aus äh aus Korona gründen,
wir hoffen auf einen Baubeginn, äh um zweitausendsechsundzwanzig,
Finanzierung vorausgesetzt, äh so dass Mitte der dreißiger Jahre man damit den ersten Daten rechnen könnte. Die Zeitsgalen sind natürlich relativ lang,
speziell wegen des Tunnelbaus. Je nachdem, wie man den Tunnelbau angeht, äh, dauert das zwischen fünf und acht Jahren. Da bliegt noch viel Arbeit vor uns.
Das heißt, das goldene äh Zeitalter der Gravitationswellendetektion, das liegt noch äh vor uns, und zwar ungefähr so zehn bis fünfzehn äh Jahre und dann geht's äh unterirdisch und äh im All richtig zur Sache.
Ja, so ist das. Also wir wir äh von der Momentklatur her sagen, wir haben das Zeitalter der Detektion hinter uns gelassen und begeben uns jetzt in die Gravitationsfällen Beobachtung.
Und äh der Standort Hannover wird auch weiterhin den technologischen Anschub geben. Dafür habe ich so den Eindruck, findet schon sehr viel hier stat.
Es findet äh noch viel in in Hannover bei GO sechshundert äh statt. Wie weit das in die Zukunft reichen wird, wird man sehen. Wir betreiben in Hannover im Institut auch noch einen Prototypen, zehn Meter Prototypen,
wo wir dann auch ähm speziell Quantentechnologien für die nächste Generation testen.
Super. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung zu äh der äh Technik von GO sechshundert und Gravitationswillen Detektion an sich. Da ist eine Menge äh zu holen.
Ja und äh bedanke mich auch fürs Zuhören. Heute mal wieder eine schön lange Sendung äh geworden, so soll es sein, immer schön ausführlich.
Weiter mit anderen Themen, wie sollte es auch anders sein und bis dahin sage ich.